testing one two testing this minute
thank you
okay good morning everyone it is 9 00
a.m and I welcome you to the Monday
April 17th meeting the science
technology and energy commission
committee uh as usual we'll begin our
activity today by standing and all of
you will join me in our Pledge of
Allegiance
for all
foreign
thanks to everyone for being here this
morning we have three public hearings
that we are going to conduct between now
and whenever
and then uh immediately following these
three public hearings I'm going to ask
everyone in the room who is not a member
of this committee's Republican caucus to
exit and we are going to have a
republican caucus after which we will
have lunch and then we will return
return after lunch for a full committee
work session on all of the Senate bills
that we will have heard by that time
and that is all of the Senate bills so
we'll begin this morning
by starting with a public hearing on
Senate bill 225. so I will open that
hearing and introduce
Senator Tim Lang to introduce this bill
to the committee welcome Senator thank
you members of the committee I'm Senator
Tim Lang I represent District Two
um before you is the simple commission
bill this bill was brought at the
request of former representative Pat
abrami who is the vice chair of ways of
means last year and served on this
committee as the chairman for for this
commission apparently the commission
didn't quite get their work done to be
polite and they asked for the commission
to be renewed so they can finish up they
have a couple minor issues apparently
they they feel they need to address and
finish up the commission report and so
before you as a bill bringing that
forward so he can continue his work as
as we voted on this before last term
obviously when the commission was formed
they just ran out of time by the
November 1st deadline for the report
just asking for it to be renewed so they
can finish their work
any questions for Senator Lang
representative Harrington has one so
just so we're clear on this this is
basically just a continuation of a
commission to try to solve the problem
that's been going on for years and years
and years on how to assess utility
further questions from the committee
Senator Wendy Thomas has one thank you
Mr chair
um is there a deadline for this
commission does it when does it end
so that should be if you look on page
two line
um three through five they have to have
the report completed by November 1st
2012. okay thank you very much
additional questions from the committee
representative Marner over there
it's representative murder it's thank
you I have a chance to read it now did
you put in
for the the appointees I was on the
commission last year with uh Senator
brahmi and myself with the
rest of the people in the industry
um was there an appointee here listed on
this bill for the governor employee on
this
if you look on the first page at the
very bottom number 20 line 28 number I
one member of the public appointed by
okay further questions from the
committee
seeing none thank you Senator Lang for
being here I know you have a busy day
and we'll let you get to it so thanks
again
next step we have
represent I mean excuse me Catherine
heck of the New Hampshire Municipal
Association
and they are neutral on the bill but she
wants to testify
um nevertheless so Ms heck welcome floor
is yours
thank you chairman Bosa members of the
committee for the record my name is
Catherine heck and I represent the New
Hampshire Municipal Association the 234
cities and towns in New Hampshire and
while we are neutral on the bill that is
correct these the bill and the study
that it is requesting has complicated
legal issues and Tax and Revenue related
issues and we would urge the committee
to support the continuation of this
study because we feel it's a critical
importance to comprehend and understand
any change to methodology assessing or
how this policy could affect
municipality school districts and
taxpayers
any potential change if not studied
completely and we as we heard we don't
have the data needed could trigger some
unintended consequence as we kind of
look at it at the surface so we would
hope that the the committee would
support the re-establishment of this
commission so I'm certainly happy to
well thank you very much appreciate you
being here
um
any questions from the committee for Ms
heck
seeing none I will uh thank you again
I'm looking at a pink card here that I
think could be an error
Dan Dolan from the New England power
generous generators Association did you
mean to testify on this bill you did
wow I'm surprised but I'm happy so I'll
good morning Mr chairman and and good
morning to the rest of the Committees
good to see you uh the the reason that I
wanted to to testify on on this bill is
uh last year we were one of the entities
that requested the original formation of
this commission served on the commission
with representative merner and several
other uh members and we strongly support
the continuation of the commission we do
think progress has been made more time
uh unfortunately was necessary and so
hopefully we'll we'll be able to do that
the the fundamental issue as we see it
that that drove the formation of this
commission was a unique nature of how
New Hampshire assesses and values power
plans for the purposes of property taxes
where uh New Hampshire is unique uh
nationally in creating a two-step
assessment process one at the municipal
level one done uh by the Department of
Revenue administration at the Statewide
level within two separate assessments of
of property taxes coming out of that
what we are looking for as asset owners
of those facilities is more consistency
and hopefully a little bit of
streamlining through the process part of
this also appears to have been a Vestige
of the change in the industry where
previously these power plants were owned
by utilities with full rate recovery at
the puc that is no longer the case and
yet we seem to be caught in between to a
certain degree here and again I think
given the complexity of these issues as
Ms heck pointed out as well as some of
the progress that was made in a
constructive dialogue last year we're
hopeful to be able to get back to work
and make another recommendation to the
the legislature I have copies of the
original
report from the commission done at the
end of last year led by at the time
representative abrami happy to
distribute those and certainly take any
questions that that may be helpful here
well thank you I just forwarded to
members of the committee the email
containing the report but you are most
welcome to distribute your copies I've
got them here so I might as well you
might as well uh representative McGee
has a question thank you Mr chairman
thank you Mr Dolan for taking my
question my question is around your um
statement that you're looking at
streamlining that there's basically two
different assessing processes that are
going on between dra and I guess
municipalities so uh since you've been
involved the whole time can you just
explain for us how that would be
streamlined who would take the lead that
sort of thing is that where you're
trying to go with it is to figure that
out or yeah so that is one of the core
questions in in front of the commission
and there's a few different ways to to
approach it uh you could have the state
create a single valuation that then
would be applied at the municipal and
the state level for taxes you could flip
that around you could have the
municipality uh conduct the single
assessment that that would would then be
applied at both levels you could create
a formula uh that would then be equally
uh administered for for municipal or
state or you could change some of the
overall structure of those taxes given
the fact that for example uh these are
non-utility facilities and yet are
covered under the utility property tax
at the Statewide level so there are
there's a whole menu of different
options which is one of the reasons that
I I think it it um is worth further
deliberation for the are consideration
that sounds like it Mr chairman
follow-up follow-up yeah and that the
follow-on thought is
um you mentioned that we're unique
in the United States so do we have
examples that are being considered by
the committee in terms of what we you
know might be doing to make it more
uniform uh so one of the uh the first uh
tasks that we did do is look uh at how
other states do it how both other states
in New England as well as across the
country
um uh suffice to say there is not a
standard best practice in how this is
done
there are just about every different
flavor out there with than pros and cons
through it but yes one of the elements
uh that we are trying to to look at is
what are some of the best practices
Lessons Learned we can get um from from
other places and and one of the reasons
in particular that this we in particular
have concerns and I I don't want to
speak for others but I believe there was
recognition across the commission is
that with these two separate evaluations
it creates more litigation risk both for
the the municipality as well as for for
the asset owner and again it to the
degree there's a way to centralize that
streamline that
um that I think would be beneficial to
all
okay representative munz has a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
coming in today
um as a member of the commission and are
are you is the commission looking at
some of the uh property tax exemptions
that have been given to
um
power producers in the state
including Seabrook
that were put in place to encourage
pollution control
that predate the federal requirement
that all facilities must have uh
Pollution Control
so certainly there's there's a number of
those types of elements that affect any
uh generation Source the Mandate of this
this commission was narrow to just uh uh
the the property tax value and so uh in
while there was a recognition that there
are some of those different elements
Pollution Control being a key one but
this short answer is no we were not
looking collectively at at the overall
tax liability of a facility and and
trying to to come up with some other
formula it was specific to just this
follow up so if I understood correctly
what you're doing is saying coming up
with a methodology on how the property
that should be included as a as uh
should be included to pay property tax
should be assessed
and how the values are the value yes
representative merner has a question or
a comment
more of a comment back uh a few terms
ago with the representative abrami we
had a house bill 700 which uh chip and
votes at the time had worked on pretty
hard too when we had put many many a
year worth of work in that on a study
to do this original in that bill was to
attack this problem but it took so long
just to work through all the other stuff
we left this to the side so this is just
a continuation of what we're trying to
do to get a fair assessment which I
think the com that commission back then
did a really good job putting this
together for 700 so this was what we're
trying to do now but this is a lot more
complex than
as you can see because I can tell you
right now I've got probably at least 600
Pages worth of stuff over the last
summer we met quite frequently to try to
but we they've made a tremendous amount
of progress in a lot with your help and
you know we've had a lot of good players
there at the table so uh just to bring
people here up to speed because I was
the one here from the committee that was
on there that's all thank you
further questions from the committee
representative Bernardi has one
thank you Mr chair uh so I see the uh
report deadline is one November of this
year
given the complexity that's been
discussed Now by all three of you folks
is that date reasonable or should it be
later I think it is reasonable I think
we all work better on on deadlines
particularly uh near term ones and I
will say
um as representative murder noted we did
meet quite frequently last year and I do
think we were able to make a lot of
progress particularly around the scope
of of what's the the problems statement
so to speak and so I am hopeful that
we'll be able to to get this done and
having a deadline at the end of this
year will drive a certain amount of
urgency hopefully among the commission
members too
thank you
I have a question for you the original
charge of the commission was to
determine the best way to assess power
generation and transmission and I
noticed that one of the findings of the
commission's report was to kind of
bifurcate
for Kate uh transmission and generation
can you tell us a little bit about why
that finding was made and whether
that bifurcation is one of the reasons
why you need to continue the work of the
commission yes so I think there are
there's there's two reasons for for that
the the first was
um uh for as often and hard as as the
committee uh did work and meet uh not
once did we uh in any meaningful way get
into transmission we uh Focus only on
generation and even that was more than
enough uh on our plate at that time so
one was
um trying to be realistic on on the
scope and and the capabilities that that
we had to address an issue the second is
that
um for the same reason the generation
was split off when this was originally
done on uh the distribution assets for
utilities largely because from a
regulatory and an ownership standpoint
those are are very differently situated
uh distribution like transmission
um is almost entirely owned by utilities
with rate recovery generation is not
and so um from that end generation and
transmission
don't fit neatly into a single bucket
they really do feel like separate issues
and one of the the items that that we
noted is to the degree that transmission
owners and uh the municipalities that um
that house them which is just about
everybody uh feel that there is an issue
uh similar to generation with how the
the assets are being valued that would
probably be worth a separate commission
to to look at at this point I am not
aware of anybody pushing for that um but
we're trying to to narrow our scope to
just the power plants
so as a follow-up would you expect that
if this commission was to move forward
again that it would try to tackle
transmission no and in fact one of the
the the changes we recommended in in the
report and is uh in this bill is to
narrow it actually to only generation
that that is uh one of the only
substantive changes in this bill versus
uh the the original Bill last year
thanks for that clarification
further questions from the committee
representative Harrington has one thank
you Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question so again from what you're
saying if we would have changed the bill
to bring transmission back in
two years from now we'd be sitting here
again asking for an extension on the
commission
I I think that is a realistic assumption
I would also note that one other um key
component of that is the makeup of the
commission last year and what is being
proposed as the overall makeup of the
commission for this uh iteration does
not have expertise on transmission I I
put myself squarely in that camp of I am
not the transmission guy I'm the power
plant guy uh and so to the degree there
is that interest I I think we would both
need to have a longer period of time and
um a more robust makeup on that side of
representative munz has another question
thank you Mr chair this may be a
relatively minor point but the bill is
very specific in saying that the charge
of the commission is to come up with an
approach to assess the assets of 59
power generation facilities I'm assuming
that what this is really trying to do is
come up with a methodology that will
apply not only to those that exist today
but in the future
that is correct so follow-up follow-up
so would it make sense
um to just change the wording so that
it's a that it's broader if there's any
confusion on on that matter it the the
expectation is it is both for existing
and any new that that may fall under
that category yes thank you
seeing none I'll thank you Mr Dolan for
your testimony on this bill and with no
further pink cards
I'll ask if there's anyone else out
there who would like to say something
about this bill before we conclude this
representative Wendy Thomas has a
question thank you um and I I should
have asked this of the original
presenter Senator Lang on page two line
nine it says section two of this act
shall take effect November 1st 2023 but
that's the completion date
that's the way OLS typically
writes these uh repeal sections
they figure that if the report is due on
the first it'll be done before the first
because it's due on the first therefore
you can dissolve the commission on the
first on the date of the report that's
the way OLS typically does these things
okay since no one else wants to talk
about this bill at this point in time I
will close this public hearing and we
will open a new public Hearing in a few
minutes but before we get to that
representative Doug Thomas has something
to discuss with the committee thank you
Mr chair I think we have extra time here
uh we are nearing the end of our public
hearing and exec sessions this month and
so my plan is starting in May
we want to look at the Tuesdays in May
for having some committee trips
and so I will start organizing and
reaching out to the various
organizations for some potential trips I
think one thing we have in the hopper uh
at some date is perhaps a trip to the
Natural Gas facility in Londonderry
perhaps about the Belvedere distribution
plant with the solar array on this on
the ceiling on the rooftops in uh there
and also we can look at other trips
regarding uh perhaps the more Dam in in
the Littleton Burgess power plant other
ideas or suggestions that might come up
but uh the only way that we can have
these trips I think is if we need at
least at least half of the committee
that would be going on these trips
otherwise it's kind of fruitless for
having long trips with only uh four or
five people I think and I think one that
we postponed and we would be looking at
is a trip to the eversource control
plant in Manchester picture as well so
keep those Tuesdays in mind in May and I
will put out words as soon as we figure
out which dates which trips that we can
do if you have any questions just
any comments from the committee with
regard to this proposal
representative muns
would there also be an opportunity to
bring some people in to maybe have some
to to kind of get some education on some
topics that may be of interest to
members of the committee
I'm you know the one that I'm
particularly interested in is artificial
intelligence from my point of view the
answer is yes but representative Thomas
is in charge of that so I'll let him
address that
um certainly we can do that uh if we do
that I would say that maybe we can use
one of our Mondays to uh to have someone
commit that because we do have this we
have this room reserved on Mondays and
Tuesdays so if we want to take a trip on
a Tuesday and have a presentator
presentation here on on a Monday we can
foreign thank you so we have about six
minutes so we're going to take a six
minute break and then we will con resume
committee activity with Senate bill 52.
we'll be back here promptly at 9 30.
foreign
okay everybody it's 9 30 and I would
like to open a public hearing on Senate
bill 52.
and Senate Bill 52 in case you were not
aware is relative to the regulation and
operation of electric vehicle charging
stations and we have Senator Tim Lang
who is the Bill's Prime sponsor here to
introduce the bill so Senator de lang
the floor is yours thank you Mr chairman
thank you members of the committee again
I'm Senator Tim Lang from District 2.
that runs from the east side of 93
starting at exit 20 and going all the
way up to exit 29. that's the New Jersey
and me talking right now
um so what you have before you is a bill
relative to electric vehicle charging
stations and so I I'm going to kind of
well I'll talk about the bill I just
want to explain why this bill was put in
um so this bill is about electro
electric electric charging stations here
in New Hampshire and what we're doing to
promote them or have them happen and the
reason why I remember not a member of
the Science and Tech committee or the
Senate science or Tech committee put
this in is because I was concerned about
New Hampshire's actions as it relates to
tourism
I'm the chairman of the Senate Ways and
Means Committee so I look at my uh
revenues when it comes to rooms and
meals tax on a regular basis and I look
at what's going on in our communities
around us and as I had discussion about
this with various members we were
discussing the fact that
um Massachusetts is seeing a significant
increase in electronic in EVS being
registered in 2020 they only had two
percent in 2022 they already have seven
percent where that's going to go in the
future when you consider the fact that
over 40 percent of the airbnbs booked in
New Hampshire is booked by people from
Massachusetts
um so I was concerned about the fact
that absent a good charging
infrastructure we may potentially start
seeing problems with our tourism given a
person from Massachusetts who might want
to take a drive up and go skiing at say
Loon Mountain but with the absence of
any charging station you can't get back
home so he decides to go over Sugarloaf
or go over to may go over to Vermont
instead I wanted to at least start the
conversation
about what charging stations uh being
available mean for the State of New
Hampshire and especially as it relates
to things like tourism and and the
impact it could possibly have
the Senate Transportation committee
amended this bill which was completely
okay with me and they created the study
Commission because we do want to
evaluate and study uh what's going on
and what the impact of the State of New
Hampshire this bill was an attempt at um
you know there's that that saying when's
the best time to plant a tree and the
answer was 10 years ago right the next
best time is to do it right now
right and so my goal was this is we
didn't plant a tree 10 years ago but we
can look at this right now and make sure
that we have the infrastructure in place
to help
um I I the other thing that was
important to me in this conversation was
the fact that the Make Ready work that
needs to get done again the work that
happens between the pole and the meter
um that is borne by the utilities
in this instance should not be pushed
down to the rate payers and that was one
of the reasons why I wanted to have this
conversation that if the state takes
action and we think that it's important
that we start enabling and creating this
infrastructure that it doesn't raise our
rates it's not pushed to the utilities
and utilities are forced to do work
which would then go to every single rate
payer so the idea behind this was start
a conversation about where revenue
streams may come from whether it's the
federal infrastructure bill that we
assign money to to do this or otherwise
and that's the reason for the study
committee so I'll take questions but
there are a lot smarter people behind me
that can probably answer any technical
questions you have a lot better than I
can
thank you Senator Lang so representative
Corman has a question for you
thank you Mr chairman thank you senator
I'm also wondering about uh people who
have EVS who live in New Hampshire but
don't have access to home charging they
live in an apartment or just you know
they they won't be able to charge at
home is this bill intended to help those
New Hampshire residents so again the the
topic as you look at the study committee
is pretty broad so that could be scoped
in into their conversation Point
um so the answer is I guess yes to that
the study committee can look at that and
and decide if there's action that's
necessary but that was not the intent
Bea has done a commissioner Caswell it's
done a great job at putting together as
a summary of of
um tourism in the state of New Hampshire
and Nev availability and and has a
pretty good head start for the committee
representative Noel has a question thank
you Mr chair thank you for taking my
question uh
is it your intent in the bill or I'm
trying to understand who would be taking
the lead in
in doing the installations would it be
the state of New Hampshire directing
money out there or is it being are you
intending to encourage Private Industry
is that the topic of discussion for the
commission so thank you and again that's
going to be a commission but the
intention was not to have the state
install right it was this public-private
partnership kind of arrangements that we
do on a regular basis in the state of
New Hampshire we believe in but again my
big concern was I think this is an
important issue and we know that and
again there's people behind me can talk
in more detail but I know recently there
was a two million dollar Push by puc to
have the utilities do the Make Ready
work which again is going to be
recoverable cost for on rates and so
when I saw that I was a little concerned
about that and one of the reasons I
brought this forward is that is to have
the commission one of the things you
should look at is what the availability
is outside of forcing the utilities to
do this make ready work and push costs
back down to ratepayers
representative Doug Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair
um thank you Sandra for taking my
question uh as you probably know there
is a house bill that's going to um
re-establish a commission for looking at
EV charging stations to assess uh Road
fees that could be collected from them
do you see this as a potential of being
blended into that commission that they
could talk about instead of having all
these other commissions can be scattered
everywhere
so again I I guess I wouldn't be opposed
to making that look but again my my view
again I did this as chair of ways and
means is I'm more I was concerned about
um our revenues as it relates to tourism
and what's going on with tourism and how
we can best use infrastructure to
support tourism in our state which is
the one of our Prime Revenue sources in
representative merner has a question
yes that you're on ways and means on the
Volkswagen mitigation fund has any of
that gone out
so I I don't know whether it's gone out
but I did ask about that fund when in
the original iteration of this bill and
what I found out was that it's only for
behind the meter not in front of the
meter it's been allocated but I don't
know whether or not any actually I do
know some of the revenues have been
spent I just don't know how many
yes uh before you follow up I want to
point out that uh Rebecca ohler is here
from the Department of Environmental
Services and she's available to answer
questions
and she might be able to answer a
question about the Volkswagen mitigation
fund so just be aware of that okay
follow-up representative Werner I guess
you could do the follow-up on it no
because
when I I did a big ribbon cutting up at
the AMC Center they put a big charging
station up there which really helps a
lot of the people coming in
um that we hadn't even touched that
mitigation fund we had set out a new RFP
and all the other states like Vermont
Maine all this charging stations they
had already used all their money for the
for the Volkswagen fund that's why I was
asking the question with ways and means
well again so I I do know that Maine and
Vermont are way ahead of us in terms of
how they're implementing and what
they're implementing and it's one of the
reasons why I have concern about New
Hampshire
representative Harrington has a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question Senator uh just
looking at this thing I'm trying to get
fathom this a little bit of talks on the
last page about identify additional and
determine the feasibility of
non-rate-payer sources of funding which
first tells me there must be some rate
payer sources of funding then it lists a
bunch of other taxes uh only one of
which seems to be specific to people who
own electric vehicles so is this bill
encompassed that everybody some way or
the other is going to be paying for
these charging stations whether you own
an electric vehicle or not
so again that's up for the commission my
point is I want to start the
conversation
so that would follow up
follow up so under this bill that's
something they should be they could be
looking at to say so if I drive up from
Massachusetts to go to Lake
Winnipesaukee I can go to a charging
station for free possibly or however
well again so one of the things in here
if you look on that fourth page line
number three surcharges on electricity
purchase through the public vehicle
charging stations so they are looking at
the possibility of surcharges again
there's no defined path if I had a
defined path I wouldn't need a
commission the point of the commission
is to have the conversation see what the
best path for New Hampshire is all right
thank you
representative McGee has a question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
senator for taking my question thank you
for bringing this bill
um and uh I noticed that you mentioned
the Department of Transportation in the
bill and as a member of the easy board
from the house we had a presentation
from dot about EV charging and what the
sort of feds were coming down with a
plan to try and make sure that this
infrastructure from coast to coast it's
always a question of who knows what when
where we're all at in terms of changes
in technology and infrastructure but
their presentation to us did provide
um
a plan that's being put in place for
where charging should be located in the
state on the highways off the highways
that kind of thing so there was a sort
of a standard being applied from coast
to coast
uh similar to what they used to do with
gas stations to make sure people
wouldn't run out so I didn't know how
much they were involved in the
discussions around this or how much it
informed
um
the inquiry so I did have conversation
they give you a question I did have
conversations with Tes I'll said some
conversations with DOT again I think the
idea was to have a uniform plan well
they have a plan they don't have funding
sources who's going to pay for this is
the rate payer is it gonna that my
concern was the cost of the work between
the pole and the meter and that and and
that is where this conversation came
from there is money available to federal
government from behind the meter for the
people who buy the charging stations and
do that but the Make Ready work was my
concern because that's going to hit the
rate payers of New Hampshire and so the
whole one of the points of the
commission is to see if there's ways we
can we can deal with that whether it's
the mitigation type of fund funding or
otherwise or I know there's a large
National infrastructure Bill coming or
has passed I'm not sure where it is in
the federal government at this point
when I introduced a bill it hadn't
passed yet
um so again whether or not we can get a
federal ear Mark that would allow us to
do some charging stations or not
again my biggest concern is I don't want
to move forward if it's going to cost
every rate payer more money I want to
find another solution and what that
solution is maybe a surcharge it may be
finding federal dollars it may be a
private partner relationship I don't
know what that looks like hence the
reason for a commission follow-up yeah
and the follow-up would be I think under
the fiscal note it mentions the 17.2
million
under the nebby program and
[Music]
um
15 million dedicated to the installation
of EV Chargers so again you're you're
still looking at the behind the meter
connection costs
being passed on to rate payers and how
we can look at it mitigate it figure out
where it comes from correct okay thanks
representative munz has a question thank
you Mr chair and um over here
yeah okay and uh thank you for uh for
introducing this bill it is a very
important topic and I'm glad we need to
not only talk about it but need to get
get to work
um question for you is
um in addition to the commission this
special commission being established the
bill also
directs the Public Utilities Commission
to complete some work over a two-year
period And I guess I'm wondering if
there's going to be any if the those two
commissions could end up working at
Cross purposes and and would it be more
appropriate to have the puc weight until
the commission has completed their work
so thank you for your question
um Sam can Mr Brown can talk about that
because I think he's been trying to get
that language Struck from this bill
twice now and so he thinks the same he's
in of the same mind that we should have
a single path
thank you great minds think alike
representative Wendy Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair
um whenever I bring up um Evie's uh on
my town form or anything I always hear
about the slavery of children mining
lithium always that's a that's a really
common talking point I'm sure you heard
it about this Bill I'm wondering how did
you answer that talking point
so again this bill isn't about EVS about
EV charging and and the federal
government you know California a bunch
of other others in Massachusetts has
made commitments to improving to have
EVS
um within their state in a certain
percentage but that's not what this bill
is about so I don't want to get down the
weeds of that conversation I agree with
you I think that's a horrific issue and
and it needs to be addressed the mining
of these precious metals and and
materials are a problem but that's not
what this is about this is about the
state of Massachusetts has just
increased the Rev total of registered
Vehicles by five percent in less than
two years and if New Hampshire doesn't
do something to provide infrastructure
support for those Vehicles we
potentially could lose Ways and Means
and and tourism Revenue in our state
representative Corman has a question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
Senator Lang uh page two line 32
mentions universal access and that's
also in the current statute that that
would be amended by this bill
universal access can actually mean a lot
of different things in the context of
the RSA and the bill
do you know what it means
I'm going to leave that to people
smarter behind me I don't have an answer
further questions from the committee
representative Summers has one
thank you Mr chairman thanks for taking
my question just for clarification I
know it mentions in the bill
um page four line three surcharges and
electricity purchased through public
electric vehicle charging stations I
just want to verify to clarify does that
mean that I understand this covers the
paying for the charging stations but is
there any risk to rate payers paying for
the actual charging of vehicles
so again this is a commission to study
all of those issues my goal would be
again that rate payers should never pay
for the charging of someone else's
vehicle and and the cost of electricity
needs to be covered by the person who's
covering the whose vehicle that's being
charged but again I you know this is a
commission to look at all of those
issues and to make sure that they're
addressed to make sure that there isn't
um you know rate payers paying for
vehicle owners
okay representative partial has a
question
thank you chair of always and thank you
for being here today
um
I keep on hearing the word commission
but I'm seeing on page three
um line 23 study committee established
and there's the difference between study
commit I just want to make sure that I
do understand there is between the study
committee and study Commission I'm sorry
you're correct it's a committee I was
using the words interchangeable other
okay anybody else have a question
representative Nutter has one uh I just
I had the same question so thank you for
clarifying that
representative McGee has another
question yes it's actually not a
question it's a clarification I I
actually am an EV owner who's traveled
out of state and I just wanted to let
people know that when you charge it's
the same as putting a gas pump in your
car you pay for it so that's how it
works
further questions I have one quick
question for you
uh you in your testimony you made
reference to make ready work
and on lines 18 through 20 of page one
of the bill it talks about front of the
meter or Utility side and the definition
of that and talks about polls Wireless
was the purpose of that language to get
that definition into statute
or is it referenced elsewhere in the
bill
so again remember this bill was amended
so that was originally as part of the
conversation I had before that it was
the other languages ripped off in this
and and the and the committee was put on
it but I do think it's important because
that was the focus of what the
conversation was about when I introduced
this in the Senate Transportation was
the front of the meter work the back of
the meter work uh behind the meter has
um
there's monies and private Partnerships
and other ways people can do that it was
my concern was the front of the me to
work to make sure that it never got
charged to a repair
so did the bill as introduced have
language with regard to that that was
stripped out it did I believe if I
honestly have to go back and look at it
I can't remember but I believe it did
because that was the focus the focus was
for me was to make ready work of the
front of the meter work and making sure
that utilities after like I said puc put
2 million told the utility to spend two
million dollars on Make Ready work and I
was concerned I was going to get pushed
to ratepayers
okay thank you
representative Nutter does have another
question thank you just one more we have
paid researchers here
um have you why not utilize their them
to do their job rather than form yet
another committee when we already have
over a hundred
so again while while they they will
again I'm gonna answer this and this is
my my understanding although I could be
wrong so again unders trying to evaluate
and understand what the impact which
some of it I did do and is why I formed
the commission because we the point of a
commission is or committee is to make
recommendation for the legal changes for
Law changes what we should Implement if
there is anything to implement into law
and so while I did have some
conversations with research to talk
about can we monetize how much ways it
means with you know our revenues would
potentially be reduced if we take no
action and I had those conversations I
felt it was more important to have more
foreign
partial has a question
thank you again chair
um it was mentioned earlier about uh
including uh surcharges on uh electric
metering in order to support Road tax
um
and there's also I know of another bill
that's that speaks of infrastructure for
EVS within the state and making sure
that infrastructure is provided at the
time of construction rather have to go
back and retrofit whenever possible are
you open to amendments that would
address these particular issues it seems
like they may fit within the study group
however I know you don't want to make a
Christmas tree out of this unless
ornament too much
I know this is a very smart committee
and if you guys think it's in best
interest of the bill feel free
thank you so much
representative munz has another question
thank you
um I I guess you know now that I'm
looking at the bill and and realizing
that we're talking about a study
committee in light of the issues that
you've raised which I think are all very
valid
should it really be a commission so we
have some outside input into the process
so because
I think it was last year we passed a
bill in chapter 14 that says that commit
once you start adding people from the
outside you have to make sure that the
legislators outnumber the public
participants whereas if I create a
committee you can have as many public
participants as you want I don't have to
worry about the number of legislators so
that's a new house rule actually
okay see no further questions for
Senator Lang I want to thank you for
being here Senator enjoy the rest of
your day and I'll next call on Michael
Licata from eversource to give us his
perspective on this legislation proposed
legislation
good morning Michael Licata representing
eversource in support of the bill uh I
think the bill sponsor did a fine job
talking about uh what the Bill's intent
is and what it's trying to uh the issue
it's trying to solve uh really the
challenge that we see on the electric
distribution side is that there are
different levels of EV Chargers as I
think the committee is aware one two and
three uh by and large the level three
Chargers those are the most uh the fast
Chargers superchargers uh direct current
Chargers
um because they pull so much electricity
in a very short period of time they can
charge an EV for around 30 minutes
compared to a level two charger which is
equivalent to sort of the hookup for
your electric stove or uh dryer which
could take you know eight to ten hours
um because of that it can result
depending on the location that they're
getting installed the need for
significant Make Ready work for the
utility to make sure that the
electricity is there to to meet that
demand and so uh as uh
Senator Lang that can be uh you know an
economic barrier for the installation of
these Chargers we certainly understand
um that you know there is a an economic
development component of this and so we
think that a study committee looking to
review different options different
sources of funding Federal funding
obviously there's there's quite a bit in
recently past legislation at the federal
level is is a good way to go and you
know the utilities I think eversource
stands ready to to work with the
committee and provide our knowledge and
expertise to try to help sort of crack
this problem and with that be happy to
answer any questions the committee may
have
representative McGee has one thank you
Mr chairman and thank you Mr locata for
taking my question
um since we have had uh we've been
informed by many of the car
manufacturers in the country that are
the most popular that they're
transitioning uh toward more electric
vehicle
product uh has eversource undertaken any
planning uh in advance to kind of figure
out where they might need to have you
know level three charges versus other
types yeah we we do uh as you might
imagine quite a bit of system planning
uh we are you know we look at at Trends
and uh predictions on electric growth
that are put out by ISO New England we
run our own studies
um to to confirm that and you know it
isn't
um
we don't make predictions on you know
hey in downtown Portsmouth they're going
to install for level three EV Chargers
therefore we need to do X Y and Z before
um they would occur it's it is you know
the utility uh business is very cost
cause or pays but we do look at at the
necessity of meeting demand making sure
that we have a robust and resilient
distribution system to to meet what we
expect uh from a reliability perspective
and follow up follow up and does it does
it make it more difficult from your side
that many people like myself and my
husband charge at home so you know
people don't have gas stations in their
garages but in this case the ability to
power up for your needs may not
necessarily be reliant on uh well
located superchargers
so far home charging uh has has not been
an issue
um certainly is uh there's increased
Eevee adoption increased electrification
of the heating uh sector you know we
continue to evaluate our infrastructure
is the Transformer that serves uh say a
neighborhood correctly sized does it
needs to get increased so those are our
continued evaluations right now
um certainly the the rate of adoption in
New Hampshire and even other New England
states it has not uh that's the best of
my knowledge caused an issue with that
but as greater electrification of these
sectors occurs that is exactly the type
of planning that we we look at
representative Doug Thomas has a
question
okay thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question so um projecting
forward uh and looking at all of the
rest stops we have on the interstates
here in the state and the number of gas
stations or pumps that are at each rest
station if we were to get to that point
of number of EV stations and let's say
hopefully before I'd ever use one that
you can recharge in 10 minutes
would that require additional
transmission lines to be put in what
kind of infrastructure at that magnitude
at that point would would we have to do
then yeah that's a pretty rigorous
analysis uh that you're you're thinking
about there
um that you know obviously I don't have
uh has not been done uh that said
um you know additional electric usage uh
results in the need for additional
infrastructure whether that's starting
at the distribution system the
transmission system and ultimately
um increased need for electric
generation uh so I I think it's a fair
statement to say that uh increased
adoption of electric vehicles increased
adoption of you know electric heating
results in the need for additional
um uh investments in infrastructure
follow up thank you so uh is it your
opinion that the study committee could
perhaps even address that level of
magnitude uh during the study committee
I I think that certainly the committee
has a very wide uh scope and uh you know
I don't know if I think it's really
looking at the distribution level
um make-ready work and different funding
sources but looking at projections for
electric vehicle adoption uh which would
I think play into to your question uh
would be I think very helpful uh for the
committee to sort of level set where are
we now where do we expect to go
representative Reynolds has a question
thank you Mr chairman
and thanks Mike for being here
um your statement that it is the Make
Ready work the um infrastructure between
the
you know the distribution line and the
trans to the Transformer to the charging
station
um Rings very true to me in my personal
experience uh
charging even at
so-called DC fast charger or
supercharger locations at say at The
Mall of New Hampshire the Electrify
America station there or or the same
Electrify America station at the
Seabrook Walmart plaza I rarely
experienced the rate of charge that
would live up to
you know the billing uh I.E charging the
car in 30 minutes and this these are at
locations of course you know at malls
existing malls where you would think
that the infrastructure is enormous and
robust is can you provide any any
insight as to why that might be the case
and it personally it's sort of
discouraging for the you know the few DC
fast charging stations that do exist in
the state
at these locations that they actually
don't deliver the rate of charge yeah
that you would expect
before you uh answer that question and
I'm going to allow it but remember we
need to confine our questions to the
bill before us
go ahead I guess yeah I I I
unfortunately I I don't have insight
into the the particulars of those uh
specific locations
um I I couldn't say whether that's uh an
issue with the Chargers the we'll say
behind the meter work or uh an issue
with
thank you representative uh or an issue
um you know the
uh the infrastructure in front of the
meter uh so you know if if the owner of
those
um stations is not seeing uh you know
the the performance and they identify it
as an issue uh on the front of the meter
then certainly we would work with them
and uh to try to address that
thank you Mr chairman for
uh representative Bernardi has a
question and before we I allow that
question I'd remind representative Wendy
Thomas that we need to be careful about
touching the equipment here
um we can get we have other people who
need to do that kind of thing so just
just be careful yeah
so um if if there's an issue like I
couldn't see any speaker so do we have
to notify somebody who do we notify we
really should okay all right okay
I I'm not chastising you I'm just
pointing out that that's that's a
reality that we have to live with okay
representative Bernardi has a question
thank you Mr Speaker uh so Mr Lakota is
the order of magnitude of federal funds
that are referenced in the fiscal note
in in line with your expectation of how
much Make Ready work is going to be
necessary or are we way off or you know
what what's your assessment of that
I I
um
I don't want to kick uh the the question
over to to miss Oller although she might
be better equipped to to speak to the
availability of federal funds and their
their potential uses
um it really is very difficult I had a
number of these similar conversations in
the Senate is really very difficult uh
to put one's arms around the scale of
the need
um and that's that's for a number of
reasons one how many of these fast
Chargers are required what locations and
then each location is very site specific
you know you might be able to get by
with very minimal work to make that uh
interconnection there could be areas
that are more say well rural in nature
uh you know an error bed and breakfast
that sort of thing if they want to
attract folks uh that would require
quite a bit of of investment so it is
it's hard to get one's arms around it
because it is so very site-specific and
and we don't you know to representative
Thomas's question you know how many of
of these fast Chargers how many level
two Chargers are acceptable you know
could the in get by with a level two
charger that charges Navy overnight so I
I know that's probably an insufficient
answer but um you know I think Miss
ohler might be able to speak to
the specifics of what funds could be
used for
follow up
thank you uh I guess Miss Oller is
listening uh you can anticipate my
question
representative Corman has a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you Mr
locata uh I'll ask the same question I
asked before do you do you know what
universal access means in the bill and
in the current RSA
um if you could point me to the section
of the bill I apologize sure uh page two
um
so thank you very much for the reference
I know that there is
um
uh on lines 10
through uh I think 12 uh there is a
discussion about uh needs to be
accessible to the public 24 hours a day
seven days a week I think that was sort
of the intent I know it doesn't quite
align with universal access uh but I
think that was the intent to say that
this is is available
um uh you know to the public follow-up
so so you don't interpret it as meaning
that it could charge any EV or that it's
uh for people with with various
handicaps uh on the advice of council uh
I would suggest that uh that is what it
means it is not uh specific to one car
manufacturer for example Tesla uh is
only equipped to to charge their own
cars
okay seeing no further questions from
the committee we're going to move along
here and I'm going to ask Sam and
business Brown of clean energy New
Hampshire to give us uh his perspective
on this legislation
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee uh Sam Evans Brown executive
director of clean energy New Hampshire
um I I thought I could answer some of
the questions that I heard that that I
knew the answers to but one was just uh
swatted down so so I'll take on some of
the other ones
um I think that maybe just us to start
though we should we should realize that
there's there's also a tremendous
opportunity I mean there's a real
challenge when it comes to the adoption
of electric vehicles and making sure the
infrastructure is in place but when it
comes to reducing electric rates there's
there's a real opportunity here electric
vehicles represent the ultimate in
flexible load you plug them in
um you know whenever whenever is
convenience but they they don't
necessarily have to charge the moment
that you plug them in you can have them
programmed so that they'll respond to
price signals and can fill in The
Valleys in our electric demand and for
those of you who are on this committee
who are familiar with how utility rates
are set it's a numerator and a
denominator right there's is the cost of
the infrastructure and then there's the
unit sales of how many kilowatt hours
you push over that infrastructure and if
you have more sales divided by divided
by that that fixed cost
um or maybe it's vice versa yeah flip it
around my head every time that results
in a lower kilowatt hour rate so the
fast Chargers however are a particular
challenge as you've heard the
infrastructure required for a fast
charger can be very expensive but I
would suggest that that a a robust
network of fast Chargers is how we prime
the pump so that we are able to realize
the benefits of that flexible load for
those of you who are EV owners you know
that it's not like having a gas car you
very very rarely use a fast charger
because you you charge you know it's
like leaving your your house with a full
tank every day how often would you need
to use a gas station if you left your
house with a full tank every day you'd
need it for road trips and day trips and
that's about it so we're not going to
need the same number of fast Chargers
that we have have gas stations will need
dramatically fewer but they're the
safety blanket that help folks to adopt
EVS help them feel comfortable and that
if the state designs its electric rates
appropriately we can reap tremendous
benefits in the tour in the in the form
of lower electric rates because of that
flexible load so uh that's that's my my
Spiel on the rate impacts I also want to
mention Cobalt mining it's not lithium
mining that has had the uh the claims of
slave labor it's Cobalt mining which the
electric vehicle in industry has reacted
to quite swiftly and is moving away from
using Cobalt in the batteries lithium is
a a necessary element in Lithium-ion
batteries Cobalt is not there are other
chemistries that you can they can use to
avoid that problem which is happening
already
um and and I think that's about all I
had to say because my other points were
hit by previous speakers so I'm happy to
take questions if folks have them thank
you questions from the committee
representative partial has one
I could share and uh welcome
you mentioned level 3 chargers which I
understand your logic on that I've also
heard a former question and I hope I can
get a little Indulgence on this one
as a parallel if I had a gas pump
that didn't charge that didn't dispense
yeah or something that effect I would
want the state to come in and make sure
that I'm getting my fair share as it
were and we do that we do regulate gas
pumps to your knowledge are these
electric pumps that are electric
Chargers that are supposed to be
operating at a certain percentage of a
certain time and time is money in this
case
um is there any Old State oversight on
these electric Chargers as there is on
our gas pumps I'm so glad you asked this
question there is there is not and in in
my mind it is a an issue that begs the
solution
um there's their particular uh providers
of charging that are that are uh
notoriously worse actors on this front
in terms of not uh maintaining their
equipment and so you pull up to a
station that has four plugs and only one
of them is functioning and it's plugged
into somebody else's car I do believe
that that cries out for a policy
solution because many of these Chargers
have been built with public dollars and
then operations and maintenance are not
being sufficiently covered that said uh
that when I heard uh representative
corman's representative Reynolds
question excuse me
um my first thought actually went to our
rate structures New Hampshire uh has
some of the utilities have particularly
High demand charges which are which are
it's incredibly difficult to operate a
fast charger in a utility service
territory that has a very high demand
charge so some of the charging providers
throttle the capacity of their Chargers
in order to avoid very high demand
charges which is why we have been
advocating for a number of years that we
need to be investigating to mancharge
Alternatives especially in this this uh
sort of nascent phase uh so to to and
maybe to uh to again pull the camera
back a little bit we're at a point where
EV adoption is quite low but we're
needing to build the infrastructure so
that we're ready when EV adoption is
hitting levels that that essentially
everyone at this point the manufacturers
the the grid the grid operator are all
forecasting and it gets to
um and and once we reach a level where
there are quite a lot of EVS on the road
there will be a business model that will
that will make it so that Chargers can
be built profitably by private actors
there just aren't enough EVS on the road
yet for that to be the case and so again
you know if they if you build it they
will come they are coming we have to
uh before I let you follow up
I reminded the committee a little while
ago when representative Reynolds asked
his question that if we Wander from the
subject of the bill
it is somewhat discourteous to the
members of the public who have come to
testify on the next bill
if we prolong this public hearing
unnecessarily so I'm going to allow your
question but I'm going to remind
everyone that we really need to keep
focus our questions on the on the
subject of this bill and not wander off
to discuss
issues that aren't really relevant to
the passage of this bill so now
okay thank you representative munz you
have a question relevant to the bill I
do
thank you Mr chair and thank you Mr
Evans Brown
um I was very disappointed in your in
your testimony because I waited with
baited breath for the answer to the
question I had posed earlier about the
puc's involvement and you were going to
answer that yes uh so so the the that
language I would characterize as being
vestigial it's in statute already the
POC has conducted those dockets already
and we have numerous signs throughout
this process asked for that language to
be struck and I think it has not been
struck just because of cross wires and
communication and maybe
miscommunications about about the status
of those dockets so I would recommend
that that those that language can be
removed from this bill and it would
simply be cleaning up existing statute
thank you
I'll remind members to turn off your
microphone when you're done speaking
representative Corman has a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you Mr
Evans Brown for taking my question
um I asked this question earlier and I'm
thinking about your statement about how
many EVS will start the day fully
charged and therefore don't need to use
fast charges often but we also do have a
lot of people who live in situations
where they can't charge at home I
represent a district that has many
apartment buildings many big apartment
buildings do you view this bill as being
helpful to these people
uh thank you for the question I I would
agree that if you are not able to charge
at home you will be charging on the
exact same infrastructure that is being
utilized by tourists and visitors so so
I absolutely agree I would also state
that tourists and visitors don't
necessarily need fast Chargers again I
think we're sort of thinking of EVS as
if they were gas cars and thinking that
we will refuel them just like we do gas
cars and I don't think that we will you
know I I personally think that we should
uh be investing heavily in destination
charging which is a slower charge at the
place that you're that you're going to
because there's a real benefit to
Economic Development to having a charger
on your Main Street and having folks
hanging out for a couple hours while
they while they top off their EV so uh I
would I would argue that uh if we want
to do this in the most affordable way
possible we should try to get renters to
be charging overnight on a slow charger
as well which would look more like uh
publicly available on Street charging
representative Reynolds you have a
question relevant to the bill
okay go ahead I do thank you Mr chairman
um referring back to representative
Muntz question earlier do you
think that this uh that the study
committee contemplated by this bill
might be more effective as a commission
uh even if it required adding a a
legislator or two it strikes me that
even without adding any legislators
this a study commission could include
you know the dot a designee of the dot a
designee of the Department of Economic
Development and you know A Private
Industry member
without you know adding members
but it seems like might it take a
broader uh membership
having not had the experience in my job
to have participated in many commissions
versus committees I don't feel qualified
to actually comment on which process
works better and but I can tell you that
Cleaners New Hampshire would gladly
participate fully in either process
whatever the wisdom of the committee
decides
okay seeing no further for questions
from the committee I want to thank Mr
Evans Brown for being here and
reluctantly I will remind the committee
that
Rebecca Oller from New Hampshire Des is
here to answer questions if there are
any so be thinking about that because we
have one final speaker on this bill and
that is Lynn zieber going from revision
energy
turn this on here good morning
um chervos chair Thomas members of
science technology and energy committee
my name is Lindsey Burgoyne I serve as
the Director of policy and government
Affairs for revision energy as you know
revision energy is an employee owned
construction company with over 385
employees across New England and that's
a hundred staff here in New Hampshire
between Brentwood and Enfield in 2022
alone we installed 10 000 kilowatts of
residential solar 24 megawatts of
commercial solar and actually hundreds
of EV charging projects as well which is
why we're here today we in fact own the
only public charging stations here in
Concord um located right here at the
general court lot we've learned a lot
over time as we've installed these
projects over the past five years and
we're here today in support of the bill
as you've already heard driving an EV
other than a Tesla in New Hampshire is a
little bit like driving into a charging
desert and we're really excited to to
see opportunities to increase that and
find find solutions that are going to
work right here for us in New Hampshire
as you know it's rare to find fast
Chargers in rural low traffic or
seasonal areas in the situ situation
will remain so with the extremely high
costs um so we'll talk a little bit
about what makes the business case for
EV charging in New Hampshire so poor and
how this bill will help and I promise
not to repeat things that people have
already said so we've talked a lot a
little bit
um or sorry talked a lot about the Make
Ready costs and these can really
ultimately be 30 percent of the capital
cost the total cost for the projects
we're pleased that the study committee
will dive into this exact Challenge and
evaluate both available and additional
funding for prudent utility Make Ready
Investments second there's also
operational costs Sam spoke to this as
well demand charge rates were originally
designed for steady power sources such
as in a factory and as we know EV
Chargers have really spiky load profiles
um so demand charges can can be over 70
percent of a bill that can ultimately
crush the business model as it's
unfeasible to pass them on to drivers
um during the early days of EV adoption
um again that Mr Evans Brown spoke to so
um we are pleased that this bill
addresses this and we also feel that
most other pucs and Utilities in the
Northeast have designed a variety of
programs that phase out over time to
successfully spur investment in both
urban and rural charging stations so we
feel like there are really effective
models that we could bring forth to do
this work quickly we did want to note
lastly that the amendment for this Bill
calls calls out to the importance of not
increasing cost to ratepayers and that
if EVS are charged during off-peak hours
or overnight which most EV owners do
actually without an incentive it will
actually drive down rates for everyone
and adds incremental Revenue to
utilities essentially because when we're
looking at that load is lowest on the
grid and that means that that ISO
doesn't have to increase generation
during those nighttime hours there are
quite a few studies there that I'd be
happy to share with the committee we're
confident that there are many effective
models and research to support and
enable the study committee and if the
puc is to to work on this as well to
quickly advance electrification so thank
you very much we urge you to pass sb52
and happy to take any questions
thank you for your testimony questions
from the committee representative Wendy
Thomas as one thank you Mr chair you
mentioned that you have some Chargers
here in Concord now Tesla's not really
playing Fair because you can only charge
Teslas with their Chargers we've heard
about Universal are your chargers
Universal and does that include Tesla
cars
um I am happy to get that answer for you
I am still four weeks into the job here
at revision congratulations thank you my
colleague James penfold has that um and
they'd be happy to to pull that for you
before the work session this afternoon
seeing that I want to thank you thanks
for being here and with no other pink
cards in hand other than that of Rebecca
ohler from the Department of
Environmental Services I'll give the
committee one last chance to ask
thank you chairman Vos members of the
committee Rebecca Oller Department of
Environmental Services
representative Wendy Thomas has one
the
been raised a few times regarding
lithium I know that in Maine they've
discovered a large lithium mine do you
know if there's any lithium in New
Hampshire that is not an area of
expertise of mine
remember questions are about the bill
thank you Mr chairman yes back to uh the
question I asked earlier are the federal
monies referenced in the fiscal note in
any way related to the amount of money
you would expect needed to accomplish
the Make Ready work such that the rate
payer is not on the hook for any build
out thank you for your question so the
there are two Uh current sources of
funding for EV charging 4.6 million
dollars from a Volkswagen settlement
um and Des is in charge of of in charge
of sorry uh responsible for Distributing
those funds and uh 17 and change million
that the department of of transportation
is uh going to be Distributing through
the national electric vehicle
infrastructure program
uh that is not enough money to do a full
build out for fast charging with our 4.6
million we have four four stations that
have already made it through the or four
proposals that have made it through the
governor and Council process
Peterborough Errol Lancaster and Med
nadnock we have another eight to ten
locations that we will be able to fund
so with 4.6 million we are going to get
in the neighborhood of 12 to 14 stations
built that include fast charging plus
level two uh because not all electric
vehicles can utilize a fast charger
so you know that makes 30 it's to if you
assume that uh
with the with the Navy there's you know
about three times that four times that
you know we're looking at 30 40 to 50
stations Statewide Max I would say
but again the purpose of these funds is
not to try to create an entire network
of charging stations the purpose of both
of these pots of funding is to lay the
framework so that
um you know back to the if you buy it
they will you know if you build it they
will come it's to enable the use of EVS
throughout the region and and New
Hampshire is often referred to as the
charging desert and it's because we've
we've not had the funding to invest in
so maybe this bill should be called the
if you build it they will come that's
right
representative Doug Thomas has a
question uh thank you thank you for
taking my question I'll ask the same
question that I asked uh previously do
you believe that the the the the
information uh that is wanted in this
study committee
um and the fact that we have another
study commission involving charity
stations and uh receiving uh road fee
revenue from them do you think the two
of them could be combined or instead of
having two two separate two separate
ones
thank you for your question
um as Mr Evans Brown discussed the the
committee that is discussed in here has
already happened
um doesn't mean that there's nothing
left to discuss but I guess I would
agree that we do not need two separate
bodies
discussing the same questions
follow up if uh yes there's a we passed
a bill in the house to extend the uh
commission for figuring out a way to to
collect Road fees from EV charging
stations along our Corridor and so
that's the commission that was extended
so that was the question the commission
I was referring to as to whether or not
we could either you know combine them
instead of having two two separate ones
thank you for that clarification having
participated on a previous version of
that other commission I think that there
are different questions that are being
discussed and no I do not see that as a
good mix between the two
representative lewicki has a question
for you okay thank you Mr chairman thank
you for taking my question
um I realized that there are site issues
and so forth that would affect this but
what is the approximate cost per uh
level 3 charging station uh you've kind
of threw some numbers around but I
wasn't fast enough with the calculator
to try to figure it out for myself but
you know how much are they how much does
one cost because then clearly we've got
a thank you for your question
um the the
the Chargers themselves depending on
which you know make and model you go
with a single direct current fast
charger that would be capable of of
charging two vehicles simultaneously is
going to be in the between 100 and 150
000 it could go a little on either side
of that really depends on make and model
uh and and how it's structured the the
big cost the big variable comes with
where are you located in the state and
does the existing electrical
infrastructure exist at that location to
be able to support does it you know
basically is there a three-phase power
that's that's available in the area if
not
um either it's not going to be viable or
it's going to be wildly expensive to
bring in three-phase power
um to to enable that station or even if
it's just in the area but but upgrades
are going to be needed you'd get into a
lot of costs in terms of Transformers
and and
um site work site preparation some of
which are on the Utility side of the
meter and some of which are on the
customer side of the meter and so there
representative Wendy Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair
um the VW trust that was awarded years
ago before there was any discussion
about EV Chargers EV Vehicles were there
any restrictions on how that money could
be spent yes there are restrictions
um
off the top of my head I can't even
remember what the total award to New
Hampshire was but only 15 percent of it
may be used for electric vehicle
charging infrastructure the rest needs
to be used to replace diesel vehicles
with either non-diesel vehicles or
cleaner diesel vehicles because the
violation from Volkswagen was based on
diesel emissions
representative Corman has a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question so yeah I'm looking
at this the the numbers you gave 4.6
million gets you 12 to 14 stations that
sounds like a lot per station but I'm
thinking well what's the alternative and
the alternative would be the current
infrastructure we have for
gasoline-powered vehicles uh
can you provide any comparison what's
the cost of creating a gas station and
getting the fuel to the gas station
repeatedly is is there any way to
compare those I'm going to ask you not
to answer that question it's too off
topic with respect representative Corman
I
would you take that offline and ask her
maybe later on for the for an answer to
that
representative muns you have a question
about the Bill yes
um I I wanted to uh thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question I
want to follow up on uh representative
lewicki's question and your and your
answer to that question
um the the cost uh that the the the cost
that you referenced is that just to
install the station the EV charging
station or does that also cover some of
those those additional costs that you
referred to of you know getting the
power to the station well the the cost
for the station itself for the charging
unit itself again is going to be you
know anywhere from I don't know 75 000
to 150 000 depending on the unit that
you're talking about
um but the the cost to install can range
widely I think some of our VW proposals
are you know maybe only 50 000 over the
cost of the actual charging stations and
other ones are 250 000 over because just
the the infrastructure doesn't exist
they need multiple Transformers um it's
representative McGee has a question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you Miss
Ola for taking my question
um the last I heard from you I think was
in the easy an easy board meeting where
you gave us an update and you were
taking over the RFP process for that
Volkswagen money in order to get some
people to be bidding on creating this
plan that you're referring to now so is
the cost that you're providing for those
12 to 14 stations based on the selection
of one of those vendors in the RFP
process is that how you got there yes
thank you
um we received off the top of my head I
can't tell you exactly how many but
about 20 different proposals for
charging infrastructure they were site
specific we were not seeking a single
vendor to build out across the state we
were we were seeking locations and so
that that cost that is the is the um
number of different locations that we
would be able to find follow-up
follow-up so if I'm following what
you're saying correctly
um different vendors bid on different
location build out so you you're working
with multiple vendors rather than one
yes correct
um in some cases the applicant was the
was the company or individual that owns
the site and they picked their project
Partners in other applications the
applicant was the the charging company
and they had gone out and found a
location
um so we've we're going at this from two
or three different sides
okay I'm I want to thank you Miss ohler
for being here I'm getting the sense
that the committee is struggling with
coming up with questions about the bill
and uh we're not here to have a general
discussion about EV charging so I want
to thank you and uh since you're the
last pink card I have I'm going to close
the public hearing on Senate Bill 52 and
I will open a public hearing on Senate
Bill 54 and ask Senator David Waters to
introduce this legislation to US senator
Waters thank you for being patient thank
you Mr President I didn't know if Greg
Moore was going to be here to do the
first take on this or not is he
or somebody from the Senate Office
okay I guess it's me all right there's
good morning Mr uh chairman and members
of the committee Senator David Waters
District Four to introduce some
Senate Bill 54 relative to the purchase
power agreements for electric
distribution utilities and Senator avard
is uh out of the out of the state this
week so I'm glad to be here as he and I
were the two co-sponsors on this bill
um if I may uh Mr chairman just a few
words of context on this bill we all
recall over the last year what has
happened with the egregious spikes and
energy costs and even last summer
Senator Dave Arden and I started to talk
about what other
states were doing about this and of
course we got to December when
eversource had to go into the
energy Market it really about the worst
possible time because we require them
every six months to go in and people
noticed that New Hampshire energy Co-op
electric energy Co-op which uh could you
know stack their contracts and have
longer periods for a while had much
reduced costs so that was the origin of
um of this of this bill and you will
notice that there are a lot of changes
made in the Senate on the bill because
it started out specifying only renewable
sources is what Senator Evart had come
up with but I think we came up with a
much better Bill and one that I really
can thank Chris Elms and doe in the
governor's office and you know
colleagues on the on the committee and
Advocates coming towards a bill which we
think will help lower New Hampshire
Electric costs and I think also achieve
some of the goals of the original bill
to help us to diversify our our energy
energy resources and uh you know in
particular it does go to
um fuel neutral you know that the the
utilities can go to any Source but it's
it's my feeling in this bill and the
framework of it and just where things
are in the industry that it really is
going to mean that newer newer energy
and more renewable energy resources will
have a good opportunity for the
utilities to take advantage of the
reduction costs of providing a new
generation from those those services so
I think we've you know very good a very
good approach here and one which I think
we can we can get get through and have
some success with um depending on the
wisdom of this of this committee
so the findings are what they are
um it does certainly uh call out the
Natural Gas
issue
um and retirement of baseball generation
resources and of course there's a big
International context here and you know
my own feeling was that we also as a
state have fewer of alternative
um sources than some of our other states
around us who have developed other
sources more quickly but be that as it
may
um you know on line seven and eight
we've got to find develop reliable
low-cost electric supplies and have a
contract structure which lets us take
advantage of of those for the people of
the state
um so what this does is that it allows
uh electric distribution companies to
enter under purchase propose and enter
into purchase power agreements
potentially up to 20 years but for
different lengths than than what their
required uh to do now I think that word
there uh May is important
um some states mandate this I think for
New Hampshire as it says in line 18 and
elsewhere May utilities may elect to
this state they're the good judges of
the markets and what energy resource is
going to be out there and uh I think
that will that that's the kind of
flexibility that that we need and gets
us away from a state mandate as well
which is important
you'll notice on 21 to 24 I think
another very important area of
flexibility here in these purchase power
agreements because it is quite possible
that one utility can leverage a better
price in a contract if they go in with
other utilities and one crucial change
that we made here is to say that it
wouldn't have to be just in-state
utilities but also could be out of state
utilities this is important I think
particularly in major new energy
resources like offshore wind the six New
England Governors received a
presentation a couple of months ago
about the wisdom of entering into
multi-state agreements both for power
procurement from offshore wind and also
for the transmission
projects to do that as that will
probably get the best price and protect
the interests of the state's regarding
that industry so that's an important
addition from the version we first had
in the Senate that we could also go
without a state the utilities
I think aligns 25 to 7 27 this is a an
issue of the interconnection costs and
you're familiar with that in our
discussion of Senate Bill 166 that how
we're going to have if new resources are
coming online the interconnection costs
can be substantial and so we have to
account for that here I know there's
some anxiety among the community power
folks that think that including this
here has potentially covered in these uh
agreements might in some ways create
somewhat unfair competition with
projects they want to do but actually I
think that this is in accordance with
what community power wants to do because
we've heard about these interconnection
costs and so this would be a way for us
in these contracts to recognize that
that is going to be a cost to make sure
that we can get these lower lower costs
and more reliable electric supplies to
our consumers
um the process here I think is really
good in terms of ensuring public comment
of course when it goes to the puc
there's public comment there but prior
to that please note on lines 28 and 29
that we've included that there will be
consultation with the Department of
energy and then crucially we added in
the Senate and the office of the
consumer advocate so we'll have the
voice of the government and the experts
there looking out for the interests of
low-cost power for our rate payers and
we'll have the voice of the consumer
Advocate there to make sure that all
voices are heard as well in that process
um we've heard before that we probably
this has been complicated we need to
hire some Consultants that's a
recoverable cost so you see that page
two in section four there
um then we have some guard rails around
the uh size of the projects um you'll
see lines 12 through
16 there defining how much power can
come in under these under these uh
agreements and then um I think really
kind of smart and interesting ways that
this came forward working with utilities
in doe about new and incremental sources
noon incremental sources because it it's
not just news sources but it might be
incremental that there are
power suppliers now who could expand
their capacity
um I'm really interested in the
possibility of current power plants
maybe shifting over to hydrogen as you
know or a combination of of large
large-scale solar or other kinds of
things too so I think that's important
that we're saying look you know all the
industry all the suppliers can be
players in this and I think that's
important so that they can compete they
can figure out what kind of projects are
going to work for
um work for them
um and then again some I think really
important consumer protections we have
added in here several in several places
to make sure that we have the just and
reasonable language down in on in the
public interest on lines 33 to 34 and
then continuing on to page three you'll
see the correct criteria that are set up
here to make sure this isn't the best
interest and most costs effective to our
rate payer so on page three line three
cost effective to Electric grade payers
now personally I think that means that
what's going to be most cost effective
in these sources coming down the road
well I think we're seeing in the
marketplace right now it's going to be a
lot of renewable sources but it might
not exclusively be them
I think that
this this uh understanding lines five or
six that you know we are hammered
because of the winter right and having
to go out in the spot Market to get gas
when it's very high and the issue is
about LNG going to Europe instead of
coming here and you know the reliability
of wind of solar wind is strong in the
wind but solar not in the winter
this wind is stronger in the winter
solar weaker vice versa in the summer
but reliability there I think what's
important too on five and six is that
um we have a potential for storage and
we've passed some good laws to make sure
that storage can be in this um mix in
terms of long duration winter cold
events diversification of New Hampshire
electric energy sources I think that's
just key we all know that we got over
reliant on on gas and and Seabrook uh
you know good thank goodness for
Seabrook and you know over the years but
something you know if there was a if
there's a problem there or if we see a
spike in um what we've seen in the
natural gas then it we have
diversification is going to is going to
help us and this bill can help with that
then I think importantly too in line 14
we added minimized costs and maximized
benefits to rate Pairs and I just think
in this bill
for
um you know for all of us and both on
all sides of the power uh issues and
energy issues are renewable or not
renewable that that's something I think
we all can agree on that this is our
purpose minimize costs maximize benefits
to rate payers and my reading of this
bill is that that phrase really backs up
through the whole bill
because if at the point of sailing is
selling this power that's what governs
it then you better be sure you developed
resources all the way through this that
make a nice cost and maximize benefits
and then at the end
um we have to recognize the uh the the
co-ops that aren't regulated utilities
who are already doing some of this and
we're saying you can do you know go keep
keep as you were that you can do what
you do uh and um you know how to do it
so thank you Mr chairman
foreign
thank you Senator appreciate you
introducing this bill that was a
comprehensive explanation of how it all
works
but I'm sure that the committee will
have a few questions for you and I'm
going to start by asking a question
about the provision that you discussed
on page one that allows New Hampshire
utilities to partner with out-of-state
that does sound on the one hand to be
like an attractive feature of this
legislation
but what concerns me and what I'd like
to hear an explanation about is that
on page three of the bill lines
basically 15 through 19 allows
the utilities to credit or charge all
distribution rate payers the difference
between the agreement payments and
proceeds through a uniform fully
recounseling annual factor in rates
if you combine those two things together
a PPA that
has New Hampshire utilities but out of
state utilities as well
and this language about charging
distribution rate pairs
does that expose New Hampshire rate
payers to being
charged rates or or costs that
are not incurred in New Hampshire but
are incurred outside of New Hampshire
thanks for the question Mr chairman and
um my feeling on this one and I think
there are folks from doe and elsewhere
you can ask after me is that this is
exactly what would have to be worked out
and that apportionment of costs in the
PPA
as it goes to the puc because
cost effective New Hampshire rate payers
so that that's where I think that'd be a
portion out if you think there needs to
be some clarification of that point in
those lines on page
um three through working with the doe I
think that would be you know belt and
suspenders there but that's that's my
understanding of that that issue and I
will say that I've seen this already
down in the mid Coast Area in New York
and Connecticut and Rhode Island that
they are able to leverage much better
long-term power purchase agreements
um the larger they are and to get we're
not going to be able to get maybe large
enough but with our with other states we
could I do also think though that most
of these proposals are not going to
include the out-of-staters but that
option should be there
okay thank you for that explanation
questions from the committee
representative Harrington has one thank
you Mr chairman thank you senator for
taking my question
um I'm trying to look at this and
there's all these good words in here
about how cost Effectiveness and we're
going to do this and everyone's going to
review it and everybody's going to check
it out but you know the same thing was
done for Seabrook and that put Public
Service Company in New Hampshire into
bankruptcy and for years and years and
years people were paying stranded costs
on their electric bill it was the same
thing that was done for the Burgess
biomass plant we even had a safety valve
in there if you will that said if the
prices are way off Market rates then the
rate payers will be reimbursed but now
we're told by the company that
they don't have any money and if they
try to enforce that Clause they'll go
bankrupt so why is this any different
why now are we going to be so much
smarter looking into the future for 20
years and say boy we really know what's
going to be the electric prices in 20
years so we're going to sign these
long-term contracts for the benefit of
everybody when in fact the only thing we
know about future electric prices is we
know nothing about future electric
prices so why is it different now yeah
thanks for your question uh
representative and I too have been
around New Hampshire the longest
remember no quip remember
and uh and um you know I I was thinking
of Ronald Reagan you know um trust but
verify and a lot of the language of cost
Effectiveness that is now in statute
otherwise and in this bill I think it
was a result of those earlier failures
because we didn't have that as a rock
solid principle in our protection and
charade pairs the language is here
that's why it's in the bill and I think
it sends a very clear message to the puc
and to the utilities and that that that
that's what we expect in his contract
um now can mistakes be made or you know
uh I mean that's why we're here isn't it
I mean we set the policy if we see
something going off off the rails then
we can we can intervene but I I hear
exactly what you're saying and I think
that's why we have to make sure this is
this is just what that we that we think
it can work
follow up thank you yeah that's fine I'm
not going to debate obviously here but I
do have another question on the uh page
3 18 when it talks about uh all
distribution rate payers so if I choose
to go with a competitive supplier and
buy my electricity from them in this
term becomes effective I would have to
pay extra for this contract that I'm not
buying any electricity from is that
correct
I I'm sorry so I'm I buy it from a
competitive supplier let's say so I'm
not buying from the utility I don't
assume I don't think you'd be affected
by this at all but then I'm a
distribution rate pay so I have to well
I don't know I charge or credit the
difference so I would have to be charged
I'm not sure I know exactly the answer
to that that question so okay that's for
um for subsequent testimony yeah we
representative Summers has a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you Senator
taking my question uh my concern was
mostly first I'm going to fall off of
Representative harrigan's question about
the uh actually with opening in
contracts for not only not for the
ratepayers it actually looks good for
the rate payers but for generators and
bird just comes to mind as hearing as
representative Herring brought up
um is there will this eliminate the risk
of generate power generators being
locked into a contract that's infeasible
for them
well that's the question and you know I
I think this is you know it's it's hard
it's hard to know you know isn't it
about what is what the future will hold
I think the wisdom in this bill is to
not is to get us out of the lock box of
the six months going into the market
and that you know you look at layered
contracts I mean you know how is risk
allocated
or avoided right it's it's through the
capacity to have different layering and
different terms of links of contracts so
I think that's what this what it makes
possible but that's why the word may is
so important
and then all that we've got around this
with the doe the consumer Advocate and
the puc
to make sure that we aren't you know
stuck kind of holding the bag so thank
you follow follow up and then a quick
follow-up you hit there a little bit on
the six months would this if this bill
passed would it allow the the uh to be
able to bypass the puc for the utilities
to be able to go to the market more
often once every six months
well thanks for the question um you
can't bypass the puc of this bill what
it says is that they can bring to the
puc contracts that are longer
if they fulfill the criteria of this
bill
additional questions representative
Reynolds has one thank you Mr chairman
um referring back to representative
Harrington's question and I think also
to representative Summers question uh
you indicated that this bill uh
originally in the Senate was uh specific
to renewable new renewable generation
and of course it was amended as you
pointed out to be fuel neutral but isn't
isn't what's different in what is
contemplated by this bill that the peop
that such ppas would
[Music]
May well be with
renewable new sources of generation you
know they must be
new sources after 2023 whose fuel costs
um
so that's the question
you know you have to pay for the
generating capacity uh even whether the
fuel sources are but um you know I I
think it's probably most be best for the
utilities that you really talk about
what they see in these and um in terms
of the the way the bill came through I
mean I think that Senator evarts started
out thinking that the these are the
these are the the best way to diversify
is to focus on those Renewables and it
also convinced that the cost is probably
going to be the last but I think the
wisdom of moving the direction we did to
not preempt that but to say under new
and incremental that there are
possibilities for providing
um reliable and cost-effective power
supplies and that's what that's what the
market will will will teach us um but
I'm you know Mr chairman it is getting
warm and the ice is getting thin and I
think I'm skating on it and uh
glad to be here for Senator avard but um
you know I really think there's a lot of
these questions or you're going to get a
much much better answers from the folks
after me
thank you Senator I was actually going
to suggest to the members of the
committee that since we have 10 more
people who want to speak on this bill
and it's 11 o'clock already that it
might be advisable to move on so I
appreciate your comments and uh thank
you for introducing the bill next we'll
hear from
Deputy Commissioner Chris Elms and Dan
Phelan from the New Hampshire Department
of energy to get their take on this
legislation
foreign
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee uh for the record my name is
Chris Elms I'm the Deputy Commissioner
of the New Hampshire Department of
energy and I'm joined by Dan Phelan who
manages Regional electric issues for the
Department
we are here today in support of Senate
Bill 54 which we have worked on with
stakeholders and legislators through the
process the bill has a clear mission
to incentivize new resources in a
technology-neutral way
and to help address our winter
reliability problems our price
volatility problems and just the overall
cost of electricity in New Hampshire
um just to be upfront about it uh this
bill represents a significant compromise
from the Department of energy and and
where our positioning has been uh the
bill has introduced uh was not a bill
that we were able to support
um but but in working with folks
um we were able to get to what we have
before us today uh just to give you a
background on this uh the department and
and previously before the department puc
staff have historically been opposed to
power purchase agreements we are a
market oriented team we love markets and
the competitive outcomes that they
provide and
um you know we believe that other
government interventions you know have
contributed to two challenges
um so really the question is why are we
supporting this bill
you know we as we all know we are living
in extraordinary times in the field of
energy
um you know what we've seen uh with
natural gas has been historic
um there are combination of factors that
have made this kind of a perfect storm
but what we've seen is that look natural
gas is a global commodity that has
experienced extreme price volatility
which means our wholesale Market
electric markets are experiencing you
know that extreme volatility which means
our residential rate payers are going to
be also
experiencing that volatility
um but bringing it down to the regional
level our grid is built on natural gas
and we don't have the natural gas
infrastructure uh you know to meet our
needs we have a real difficulty in
working to get more and what that means
is we have a winter reliability
challenge
uh
you know we were honestly really lucky
this winter to have had a mild winter
and we're able to keep the lights on if
we end up with long periods of extreme
cold this region will see capacity
shortfalls and that means greater risks
for our rate payers and for our citizens
at the worst possible times
and frankly
given the challenges that we've seen in
the market and the need to bring in
resources to address them it's clear
that there's a desire you know to
incentivize uh building new electrons
bringing new electrons into New England
um so in light of these considerations
and the desire from policy makers
legislators to move forward with
legislation to try and address these
challenges we have put together this PPA
proposal that is laser focused on on
three things and three things only and
that's price stability that's price
volatility or you know price volatility
with with stability the overall cost and
that winter reliability challenge
this bill must be technology neutral as
we see it this bill cannot be about
giving every technology type their their
their slice of the pie we're achieving
you know other goals that are not
related to price or reliability you know
for the Department to be supportive of
this bill it can be the only mission of
the legislation
uh we would oppose any expansion Beyond
where it is now
um you know you might hear from folks
who have a difference of opinion there
is no perfect solution to this to this
problem but we do need to do something
and and there are not many achievable uh
suggestions about how we'll be able to
deliver reliable and uh you know
cost-effective resources to the region
um Senator Waters did a fabulous job of
running through the bill I think Dan's
going to hit some points of of just you
know what the bill looks like and sort
of why we wanted to put those guardrails
on
yep that's right uh Senator Waters did a
really admirable job of walking you all
through the bill so I hope that there's
Clarity in what is in the bill and sort
of how it accomplishes the agreements uh
themselves I did want to raise a few
things that are important to us and uh
commissioner Helms also talked about the
winter reliability the price stability
and the price overall effects those are
our priorities
I also wanted to raise that this bill in
uh page one section 18 or line 18
through 20 includes or does not include
to the decision of the utility the
environmental attributes of any resource
that would be part of this agreement
um
a another area that was left out is that
again mentioned 11 through 13 on page
three but I've skipped here uh so on
page two lines 12 through 16 this sets
out the size of the agreement and that
is 2 million megawatt hours that
accounts for roughly 20 percent of New
Hampshire's load and that number is uh
sizable enough to incent the right sorts
of resources that could provide winter
security but also small enough that we
are not completely giving up on the
managing markets in New England there
there's a idea that we want to have skin
in the game here and we want to show
that we're serious about meeting these
winter reliability problems and that 20
percent of load is what we think is is
the right balance for for that figure
um
another issue that was not raised is the
the timeline associated with this bill
and that is uh important to us because
there's a more immediate need here I
think we all know that this winter was
was uh eye-opening and we want to really
strike before the the
situation cools down so the RFP deadline
is in 2025 with nine months to review
after that and really getting something
done and getting things moving before
where we're exposed to too many more
winters like this is is very important
um the
conditions under which the agreement can
be approved are also important we've
talked about cost Effectiveness and I
really want to talk about the kinds the
the so page three line five uh electric
energy sources that are expected to be
available during long duration winter
events New England has a imported fuels
problem in that it can only get so much
particularly natural gas during long
duration winter events and it relies on
oil during those time periods which sees
an inventory that depletes rapidly so
the objective here is for something that
can displace that oil and natural gas
use over a week-long sort of cold event
um
and the final thing that I did want to
raise was uh line 16 through 19 on page
three which is uh the referenced by
representative Harrington uh the cost
recovery mechanism where we do in fact
intend for this to be a non-bypassable
charge we we see this as a policy choice
that is being made on behalf of all New
Hampshire citizens it's something that
will provide
price uh it'll provide price suppression
through the contract and all New
Hampshire rate payers will benefit from
uh the increased reliability of the
Electric System as a whole
um so those were the points that I
wanted to raise uh oh and one more is an
important distinction which is that we
see this as a bill for new electrons not
for bailing out resources that may be
passed their Prime so we want to prove
that New Hampshire is part of the the
region that can actually build that's
something that we in New England have
had a have had a problem with no matter
what kind of resource you want to build
it runs into problems with permitting
and local opposition and all sorts of
different difficulties we want to prove
that New Hampshire is part of the the
team that can build resources in New
England
and I'll take questions if you in the
community ask them okay questions from
the committee I'm sure we'll have quite
a few I'm going to start with one myself
and ask you that your reference to
20 percent of New Hampshire load the 2
million megawatt hour limit
would you characterize that as a
a hedge that utilities would use to try
to even out the volatility of
electricity prices
sure I think that's absolutely Fair
um so the the agreement will stabilize
prices for that portion of the load and
you can think of this as a hedge any
sort of Premium where if the cost is
above market value is essentially the
okay thank you additional questions from
the committee representative Harrington
has one
uh thank you and thank you for taking my
question
um you mentioned to follow up on the
Chairman's question 20 of the load uh my
first question would be when these are
20-year contracts are we looking at the
load as it's going to be at the time of
the contract issuance or the expected
low 20 years from now which everyone
tells us is going to go way up due to
EVs and electric heat
uh thank you for the question
representative and that's why it's uh
it's approximately 20 as 2 million
megawatt hours but the statute
make gives it that defined number of two
so let's define it okay follow-up
follow-up yeah uh the other thing I was
concerned about when looking at page two
under the definitions uh lines starting
in line 19 new electric resources and
incremental electric energy sources I've
read this probably 50 times and 25 of
the times I read it and said well
something like Hydro Quebec would
qualify if it was a new transmission
line and the other 25 percent say no
because that's not a new generation
Source they're getting the electricity
from an existing generator just being
via a new transmission line so is the
intent of the bill that we could if we
could ever do it build a new
transmission line down from Canada and
that would qualify under this and if so
do you think we need to clarify the
language so the the sort of clarifying
the distinguishing point is that these
are resources that provide additional
energy into the iso New England
Marketplace I'm sorry I didn't quite
into the iso New England Marketplace so
that that's in line 20.
so therefore a a new transmission line
interconnecting to the ISO
grid Grid in New England would qualify
as a new resource just quick follow-up
but I'm a little concerned with the
lawyers could get on this and say no no
no maybe that needs to be clarified to
say including new transmission so it's
not some good limited to just new
generation and that might not be the
case from Hydro Quebec that would be up
to the committee's discretion thank you
okay more questions from the committee
representative
uh McGee has a question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
okay so we uh we understand that we're
kind of all in agreement that we want to
do something about price volatility and
try to figure out how to help stabilize
um the energy that we're using
especially through winter Peak but I I
I'd like you to say a little more in
your intro Mr Elms you talked about
choosing technology neutral over
um uh
the general support for competitive
markets and I guess my my concern is
what we've been hearing from many of the
people that have been submitting
testimonies concern around the effect on
the wholesale markets the effect on the
competitive markets which help us to
hedge and push downward pressure on
costs so could you talk a little bit
about uh what what locking in does with
the advantages the built-in advantages
that that the utilities have in order to
roll in their costs like interconnection
and other things that other players in
the market would not if you could
um
so
the
the bill would allow essentially the the
price to
be part of the utilities rates over the
course of the agreement
um that you know takes 20 out of play
out of out of the year to year
day-to-day energy markets so the
remaining 80 is still uh
exposed to the markets and what may come
of that but this stabilizes prices by
removing that demand from
follow up so I guess my thought or my
question or concern is around what it
does to the price signals in the market
it don't let Dan speak more technically
about it but yet you know look those
those are sort of where we've had
historical concerns with government
interventions in this way you know our
state energy strategy does talk about it
goal six of the state energy strategy
says that government interventions in
the market should be limited justifiable
and Technology neutral so you know
looking at the the bigger problem right
you know the you're right there are
impacts on on the market with with any
intervention
um but that bigger problem of that we're
facing with be it price be it winter
reliability you know says to us we need
to build something we need to show that
we can build something and and incent
that and
um you know that's something that you
know this committee has to balance when
when making that policy decision I don't
know if you have anything you want to
okay representative Doug Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair thank you
is this
this is a kind of a large-scale policy
change is this intended to be permanent
or just during the period of of what
we're facing right now and how does this
um how does this fit into your 10-year
energy plan
yeah sure um it's a good question thank
you for it um so so this bill does allow
up to 20-year contracts so that is uh
you know the term that we we could be
looking at here uh there are given the
timelines in in the legislation it's not
an open-ended ability for folks to come
before the puc uh it's only the next a
couple couple years several years
um where they can bring those forward
but yeah there would be potentially
long-term you know
um effects should the puc approve a
contract of uh 20 years you know as I
said before I think in terms of the
relationship with the state energy
strategy you know um in looking at the
goals of reliability price uh you know
just cost Effectiveness and sort of that
idea that that whatever our intervention
is as sort of policy makers
um it should be limited it should have
you know an actual defined goal and it
should be technology neutral we think
this fits in with the state energy
strategy
um and and it's up to the legislature to
determine whether or not this is a
policy change that you want to make
follow-up thank you thank you for the
follow-up so uh do you feel do we have a
way if we guess wrong
like we often do
if we guess wrong and find out that it
has the opposite effect is there a way
that we can
get out of this if if we if with the
I believe the answer is no this this is
a inherent part of the risk of long-term
contracts and I I mentioned earlier that
sort of any above Market piece is is
essentially the cost of the Hedge
um so if if there's a scenario where
this contract becomes uh a bad deal
we've paid that money for Price
stability
and can I can I also just move back to
your first question
um where if I'll point you to page two
line 29 that sets an end date for the
ability of the utilities to enter into
these rfps
um there is an energy transition going
on in the region and we don't want this
to be our permanent solution but there
is a a acute need for something to be
done to stabilize prices and and move
forward
and and if I may um you know obviously
there is a risk that this is a bad deal
there's also a potential opportunity and
there have been contracts that we've
seen where where if you look at the last
year folks were able to you know find
savings for their ratepayers by having
entered into a long-term deal so that's
okay represent
representative Munns has a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you for uh
taking our questions
um I'm I'm I'm struggling with the fact
that as I understand it we have a
um a system where the utilities the
three utilities are the providers of of
Last Resort for power
they're really only there in in the
event that someone decides that they
don't want to enter into an agreement
with a with an independent power
producer
um
um why not ins instead of putting this
or instead of giving this this uh this
um
option to the utilities why aren't we
trying to do more to encourage
the power producers for the independent
suppliers
so
this is this is one piece of of the
puzzle uh we
have limited ability to direct those
suppliers to to do
much of anything it's their their idea
of if they want to play ball if they
want to walk away from their resources
that's their prerogative
this is a way that the state can direct
this investment
um
and that's through through this function
representative Summers has a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question I'm actually going to
rephrase a question I asked earlier to
the senator and that is on the uh
contract and Contra if a contract
becomes unfeasible for a power generator
where they can't afford it to ensure
that the state doesn't fall on the hook
of for it is there is there guidelines
in this current bill to foreign exit
strategy for them to actually cancel or
get out of the bill and if not should
there be guidelines added to this bill
to make to ensure that the state doesn't
fall to pay for that
um
so
the
the bill as written I believe would not
afford the opportunity for a developer
to back out and this is something that
we're seeing currently legis um
adjudicated adjudicated uh in
Massachusetts with some of their
offshore wind developments uh the the
due to the pandemic a lot of labor costs
Rose over the course from what the
utilities originally bid in they've
tried to get out of the contracts and
actually them getting out of the
contracts represents a bad deal for rate
payers because it's it's them leaving an
agreement that is now worse than market
value the therefore the utilities the
rate payers are set to receive below
Market power and that's that's actually
a good outcome for rate payers
okay lots of other folks to hear from
seeing no
representative Harrington has a question
yeah sort of a follow-up from
representative Munn's question there we
if the way I understand this there's
nothing that prevents the competitive
suppliers and a good deal of residential
and Commercial uh electric uses use
competitive suppliers if this is such a
good idea to sign 20-year contracts
why aren't they doing it and if they are
why do we need the why do we need to
mandate that or or say that the
utilities can do it without any risk at
all
I I am not familiar with the procurement
practices of the various defaults
competitive suppliers so I can't answer
that question quick follow-up follow-up
uh did in the discussions of this bill
you obviously did a lot of negotiations
you said uh one other thing that is
blatantly different between a
competitive supplier and a util a
utilities default service rate is they
sign a contract whatever the costs are
they pass on directly to the rate payers
if this contract is a good deal the rate
payers will save money if it's a bad
deal the rate payers will lose money was
there any uh discussion of the utility
taking some risk like competitive
suppliers have to do so if they were
saving the rate payers money they would
get they would make more profit but if
they were losing the costing the rate
pay as additional charges they would
make less money that would cost was
there any discussion on risk sharing
with the utilities yeah it's a it's a
sensible idea it's not one that we've
had time to work through and and it's
not one that's currently in the the
legislative station
if if it were the committee's desire to
see something like that I would I would
suggest
making that a consideration that the puc
would would need to take into account
did you have another uh no it came out
on it no that's okay thanks
all right
so you know further questions for these
gentlemen who I'm sure will hang around
in case other questions surface let's
get another point of view now and call
Dan Dolan from the New England power
generators Association to tell us about
why the
any PGA opposes this bill
good morning again uh and I'm also here
with my colleague Molly Connors I'm Dan
Dolan president of the New England power
generator Association uh what I should
have said the first time I was in front
of you this morning is uh who we are so
New England power generator Association
represents a little over 90 percent of
the install generating capacity in New
England and a comparable app amount here
in New Hampshire uh to boil that all the
way down we effectively represent the
vast majority of the existing power
generation sources
as has been
noted several times in the descriptions
of this legislation uh this bill is
explicitly about new sources of of
generation and incremental uh Supply
um we have a much more extensive uh
written testimony that I'm going to do
my best to summarize uh rather quickly
here but the the the core of of that is
that our members live and die on their
capability to be economic in the market
that they offer uh every single day to
provide the actual energy to keep the
lights on here and then uh one time in
an auction three years out every year to
provide the the capacity the commitment
to be available to provide all that
electricity because they live and die on
that competitive market any carve out
any uh subsidy for a particular resource
undermines the economics of those
resources that provide today's most
economic power and the reliability
Services associated with that and it is
why we are so consistently in front of
you all opposing those types of
proposals and why we are here today
opposing this legislation uh as I heard
the description
um uh this bill is primarily designed
around trying to stabilize and create
more affordable default Energy Service
following the the extreme volatility
that we did see last year as well as to
support winter reliability I do not
believe that this is the right
prescription
um for for any of those things in this
this current market
this would carve out roughly 20 percent
of of the market on these multi-decade
contracts and realistically given the
the current constraints that we do see
from a a sighting a few fuel delivery
and and other opportunities within the
market we look at this as as largely
about some combination of offshore wind
Canadian Hydro Imports or some small
scale solar Plus Storage maybe around
the edges again as we look at issues
around winter reliability I would argue
that those resources do not meaningfully
impact the the peak periods that we have
seen within New England we need to only
look this past winter where for despite
it being a relatively mild winter
overall we did see two peak extreme
situations during the winter one on
Christmas weekend in which we saw
roughly 1700 megawatts of Canadian Hydro
pullback during that event which then
triggered New England going into a
reserve deficiency which means not that
the lights were going out from a supply
side but that all the resources we hold
in reserves we had to dip far more into
into those Reserve capabilities than
it's frankly comfortable and then
triggers a a pay for performance and
event which means any facility that
wasn't online at that time has to pay a
penalty
which then goes to any facility that
overperformed helped ensure that we were
able to keep the lights on and and the
reserves capable a second one is on
February 3rd and 4th which was the
coldest day we've seen in decades across
particularly Northern New England but
really across the region on that day
February 4th Saturday morning for the
entire morning ramp so roughly six to
eight hours that day
we were actually sending a thousand
megawatts from New England North to
Quebec to help keep the lights on there
at the very moment that Hydro Quebec was
going on the radio and on television
stations asking for all consumers in
Quebec to conserve electricity because
not only did they have to import a
thousand megawatts from New England they
had to import a thousand megawatts from
Ontario and another thousand megawatts
from from New York they hit an all-time
Peak uh on that Saturday morning of 40
000 megawatts
and look that's the way neighboring
regions should work in the same way that
we import from Hydro Quebec throughout
most of of the year we do it today
during that period of peak winter Demand
on those two occasions when we need it
most it is not providing some of that
those core reliability services and
certainly as we look at price reduction
based on uh default energy rates my
argument is that as we do see the
existing contracts on some of those
other resources noted it does not
provide that and then where I I'd like
to end here is is touch on what has been
brought up several times which is our
history with some of these long-term
obligations trying to gaze into our
crystal ball and predict what the market
is going to do just a few years into the
future let alone uh decades we have the
example of the Berlin biomass facility
we have the example of some of the
stranded costs in other areas we also
have the example of the the scrubber on
the Merrimack station and and the cost
explosions that that came out of that
and then certainly on the other side of
the equation uh you see some of the
seller's remorse that is being litigated
today in Massachusetts and Connecticut
on offshore wind on contracts that are
less than a year old in which those
suppliers are trying to get out of that
um at its core I think there's a very
good reason that New Hampshire for a
long time has had a policy of being
enormously skeptical if not downright
opposed to the policies that are being
put forward here and certainly any state
has an uh has an opportunity has the
right to to change its policy but that
last 10-year energy plan was based on
rigorous analysis done over several
months speaking to dozens of
stakeholders and creating a
comprehensive analysis and report that
was then further considered by this body
I think a similar deliberative process
would be necessary if we're going to
make a sea change of this scale to uh to
be able to to justify carving out twenty
percent one-fifth of the electricity
Market in New Hampshire and it is for
all those reasons that our organization
strongly urges that uh this bill be
deemed in expedient to legislate and
that we maintain some of the policies
and allow
um also the puc to conduct the analysis
that is ongoing on how to better
structure the default energy rates with
that thank you Mr chairman and members
of the committee
thank you Ms Connors do you have
anything to add or you're just here to
answer questions no I'm sensitive to the
committee's time okay thank you all
right questions from the committee for
the New England power generators
Association
representative Harrington has one thank
you Mr chairman and then taking the
question there's been a lot of
discussion here today about uh and
almost a panic over what happened this
past winter electric rates exploded it
was the end of the world and uh actually
there were no blackouts but just looking
at ISO New England's output there the
actual gas prices with 38 percent lower
this winter than they were a year ago
and the real-time electric rates were 25
percent lower so we were sort of like
reacting would you agree we're reacting
to last Winter's higher prices where a
lot of people didn't capture the money
that they thought and this and this the
market settling out now and maybe it's
just not time to completely panic
so we're very good at fighting
yesterday's Wars uh and and and look
last year was extraordinary
um uh I think it was commissioner alums
noted this was an extraordinary moment
in in the energy markets and there's no
question about it I saw the most
volatility I've seen in my career uh
last year coming into the that market
coming out of uh the Russian invasion of
Ukraine and then uh the the Dual issues
of Europe on the one hand cutting
cutting off
um many of its energy purchases in
Russia then cutting off many of its
energy exports that then created a level
of uncertainty we've never seen in the
energy markets and because of the way
the default energy rates are set
uh they are snapshots and
um uh in time and expectations about
what those next six and actually longer
months are are going to be because you
have as a supplier you have to offer in
to that that six-month commitment
actually a couple months earlier so it's
it's a pretty long dated uh view overall
and certainly you're on the hook based
on how the market moves and because of
the volatility you saw a very healthy
premium offered into into those rates
the reality was that going into the
winter even before we saw the more mild
temperatures we saw inventory storage
levels up
um in Europe which then helped stabilize
the global LNG Market which then helped
stabilize some of the domestic natural
gas market particularly in the
Mid-Atlantic and we did see a more
healthy flow
in this region what that now means is we
look forward is that we are already
starting to see in some of the other
utility standard offer rates uh uh a
significant drop off from uh the the
high Winters and as we already now turn
the calendar into uh next winter we also
are seeing a a much more stable lower
price level uh as expected moving
forward
um and so yes the the reality of what we
saw this winter
um was actually a much more stable
system than frankly many of us were
concerned we were going to see last
summer and and last fall and that goes
again to some of the humility I think we
all have to have about uh what actually
happens in the market what the
expectations are and what the reality
Bears out
follow-up follow-up so what you're
basically saying is that we have trouble
predicting Energy prices six months in
advance and trying to do it 20 years in
advance is probably just a pipe dream
yes
representative McGee has a question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you Mr
Dolan for taking my question it's along
the same lines as I listened to my
colleague representative Harrington
asking about whether this is the correct
response to what we're trying to solve
we've heard a lot about the six-month
lock-in of rates being you know the
contributor to the problem that they
were being passed along even though they
might not have been staying in place
that long so
um we've talked a little bit here about
laddering some folks do laddering all
right none of us are really experts on
all of the how all that works but could
you comment on whether you think the
20-year Contracting is actually
something that would address that
particular concern because it seems like
that's what this is in response to sure
so um you sign into one of your contract
you're certainly going to get price
stability
the question is at what level right
because particularly given the
experience that we are seeing in some of
the Southern New England states around
um some of those contracts now being out
of the money for for the supplier
well if I were them uh I would then be
building in a higher uh a risk premium
within those contracts for for that
similar situation moving forward
um there is certainly a uh a level at a
supplier is going to be willing to to
lock and give a fixed price but the the
buyer is going to to Bear a a healthy
risk premium
um within that
I also think part of this is
um uh the the way that the market is set
up in in New Hampshire is to provide the
option for the consumer particularly
some of the the larger business
consumers and the larger users the
capability to go out and and negotiate
whatever term of a deal that they they
want if they do want a longer term
contract in the retail Market there are
much longer terms than just a a
six-month strip available
um
these types of decades-long
non-by-passable charge types of
contracts I I I think are very very
risky
um overall
follow-up
speaks to that as well
um as you were speaking the other uh
thought that I had was from looking at
the letters that yourself and Miss
Connors had submitted to us in terms of
an effect on the wholesale Market which
I would like to better understand so if
you could maybe segue and well
um I'd like to follow up on what um Dan
said in response to your first question
and then I'll pass that over um back to
Dan so yes you yes regarding price
stability you can by taking that much of
the of the supply or demand out of the
market you do lock people in and that
gives you
um the stability but to Dan's point you
know
um you're liking yourself usually into a
higher you're almost always locking
yourself into a higher cost for the
consumers and just as a point of example
Avon grid signed a contract in
Massachusetts in Spring of 2022 that was
a 20-year contract with a 2.5 percent
increase every year so that in year 20
they were going to be receiving 95.28
per megawatt hour and even under those
circumstances Avon grid is trying to
reopen that contract
saying it's not enough to bring to the
markets
and on the the wholesale Market impact
um it's pretty straightforward so
um by let's say it's 20 to use round
numbers one-fifth of the market is under
these contracts
um functionally speaking those resources
still have to get dispatched by ISO
newing on ISO New England is the air
traffic controller of the grid overall
to do that those resources then get
entered into that energy Market that
clears every day in 15-minute increments
as a price taker so they they have to
offer in at effectively zero dollars and
what that then means is that portion of
the electricity Market is
carved out and then means that the the
clearing price the price any other
resources would get would get reduced
because now you have
um a substantial portion of of that
market that that has disappeared and it
just moves back the supply stack
um what strikes me is that one of the
other justifications for for this type
of a policy shift is concern about
retirement of some of the the larger
scale resources it is those very
resources that are also then going to
see their economics further undermined
by this and we just kind of perpetuate
this this cycle moving forward and have
the perverse outcome of actually further
accelerating the revenue degradation for
a number of those facilities with the
very real potential of driving more
retirements and at a certain point than
it's the subsidy beget subsidy now this
person needs a bailout and and so on and
so forth
thank you okay additional questions from
the committee
seeing that let's move on thank you I'd
like to call on Sam Evans Brown of clean
energy New Hampshire to give us his
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee
um
I think maybe I would just like to take
a beat uh and talk about what uh how we
got the markets that we have today and
and how markets generally are changing
all around the world
um
Seabrook station was mentioned earlier
and I think Seabrook station is a
perfect example of how we wound up in
the situation where we are now utilities
when they were tasked with building and
operating the Our Generation Fleet had
very very little incentive to exert cost
discipline when it came to developing
new projects because they knew that they
were going to be able to get their
regulated rate of return on any Capital
that expended this uh has a a documented
a very well documented history of
leading to cost overruns that then rate
payers are saddled with that is what led
to deregulation I mean that was that was
really the the
um the the problem that we were solving
for is how to exert cost discipline when
it comes to regulated utilities
um it started with Margaret Thatcher in
the UK 1990 was the first country to to
engage in deregulation and that in that
regard our markets have worked extremely
well and I think that they're a model of
of how you can use Market forces to to
even in an area that we thought was a
natural monopoly to exert cost
discipline
um however I think we have to recognize
that our electricity markets are not a
you know perfect uh uh you know
frictionless Market of the type that
Frederick Hayek would recognize right
these are highly regulated they are
highly intervened upon they they are
they're a a they're meant to be sort of
a financial replica of a physical system
um and that is ensuring you know
economically efficient dispatch of of
whatever the lowest cost resource at the
moment is
they they have while they have done a
good job of Shifting risk from uh rate
payers to developers what they don't
necessarily contemplate is what are the
drivers of cost on the electric grid
apart from the cost overruns that that
we experienced through the 70s 80s and
90s and one of the drivers of cost on
the electric system is cost of capital
cost of capital especially when it comes
to any Capital intensive generation
asset which will include renewable
assets but also assets like nuclear can
be a substantial
substantial
element of the cost of the energy that
you ultimately receive when it comes to
renewable energy plants that can be as
much as 50 percent of the cost of energy
is just what is the interest rate on the
on you the the you know the package of
equity and and debt that is paying for
the project
um and it is because of that recognition
that many countries have have all around
the world moved towards competitive
solicitations of new resources as a new
market design and there's been a lot of
talk about this as a sort of government
intervention as if we're not already
creating and designing the markets that
are are supplying our electricity today
this is simply a different Market design
it's a competitive auction a competitive
process by which we select the lowest
cost resource for new construction
um and I will note that you know we
mentioned Margaret Thatcher the United
Kingdom is doing these types of
competitive solicitations
so while I understand that this is new
that there's a lot of discomfort with
with doing new things it's also worth
pointing out that
uh we are in the midst of a dramatic
transformation of the Energy System writ
large with new technologies that have
new capital structures and and notably
zero fuel costs and they're bidding into
markets that are designed with for
entities that had fuel costs and had
much lower Capital requirements and
perhaps it is it is worth taking a look
at the idea that that we do need new
market designs in order to confront that
that reality
um I I would point out the two ppas that
were mentioned well excuse me the two
generation assets that were mentioned
Burgess and Seabrook both were projects
that yes we were signed into a long-term
contract but there was no competitive
process to determine which power plant
was going to get built in either in
either instance there was a single
project that was considered we locked
into a long-term uh well in the case of
Seabrook locked into paying that as a
stranded cost under a previous regime of
regulation in the case of Burgess it was
just the plant that we were offer word
that's not what we're talking about here
we're talking about running a
competitive process and selecting the
lowest cost Resource as a way of
incentivizing new generation so I'll
leave it there but I I thought I just we
could bring the camera out a little bit
representative lewicki has one thank you
Mr chairman thank you Mr Brown
um having been through the ice storm and
numerous other things living in a rural
area it does seem like our default as
gasoline
and other than nuclear and fossil fuel
what can what technologies can possibly
take us through a serious winter outage
that's going to last for days
uh well so if we're talking about
outages I'm not sure that this bill is
is speaking to how we ensure ensure that
the poles and wires stay up in an ice
storm
um I I would argue you know when we look
at what happened on Christmas Eve and
why and why prices went uh wild the way
that they did it was it was a number of
generators that were tripping offline
because of operational issues associated
with with the storm and with the with
the cold but that said uh I don't think
that this bill would would uh ensure
that we have backup power at our homes
you need a follow-up
well it the same thing goes for backup
power for the grid if
um you know right generating capacity is
not there you know extended out a time
frame in the winter then where does the
power come from yeah no so so I think
the question maybe maybe I'll try to
reframe the question you can tell me if
I'm getting to what you're asking which
is that what is a resource that would
help deal with our winter reliability
problem right and I and Mr Dolan
addressed that a bit and I I guess I
would disagree slightly in that
um when you look at what's in the iso
New England interconnection queue the
resource that is at most heavily
represented is storage and and I would
anticipate that that some combination of
of new renewable resources and storage
likely are the way that we that we start
to nibble at this at this problem but
but you know just to again return to
First principles the reason we have a
winter reliability problem in New
England is a very hard problem to solve
uh and and the profile of our region is
such that that there are very few
resources that can be that can be relied
upon and why we really need to think
about building new things
representative munz has a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you again
for being here I'm going to rephrase a
question I had asked to the
representatives from the Department of
energy earlier in this in this new
energy Market that you that you've
described
um
where we clearly need more we need more
more energy
is or are what are essentially Legacy
distribution companies the right place
where we should be
encouraging this kind of new development
or are there other entities that
are more appropriate this is a great
question
um and and uh it may indeed be the case
that other entities are should be the
the ones that serve as the anchor
contract that gets the low-cost
financing that I was referring to in
particular I think uh Community power is
is something that's on the horizon that
could very well serve that purpose it's
really a question of of sort of risk and
credit rating is is what it really comes
down to and and the the trouble I see
right now is that when you look around
for who is a credit worthy counterparty
that would that a that a financer would
see as very low risk
um there's there aren't a ton of options
and the utilities the utilities are the
option that we have right now
um and you know I will note that there's
an enormous amount of renewable energy
being developed in the region right now
where the the credit worthy counterparty
are large corporations um you know
Comcast just announced that they're
they're taking a long-term PPA from a
solar project being developed I believe
here in New Hampshire I might be
speaking out a turn there but but that
that is that is a an Avenue for
developing renewable energy as we speak
um that is being accessed as we speak I
would just say that uh the bill that you
have it before you is a is a way to
ensure that not only large businesses
are able to capitalize on those on that
that hedge and potentially those rate
savings that uh those types of companies
okay representative Wendy Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair and thank
you for being here and taking my
question
your point three on your your written
testimony about
prioritizing New Hampshire jobs that's a
that's a really good point that I hadn't
even considered is it possible that we
could partner with an out-of-state
company and then all of our resources
could go
to their jobs which is why you you put
that in there yeah so so I guess the the
reason that I suggested that that is a
change that clean energy New Hampshire
would be very supportive of is because
if you can imagine that we issue an RFP
that says we want the lowest cost energy
and we want it to benefit winter
reliability and those essentially are
the two main criteria that we're
evaluating the proposals on what happens
if you get one proposal from say a
project in northern Maine that is in a
really you know it's a really great
resource and it's very competitive in
that regard but has a lot of
transmission to get it down to get it
down to New Hampshire and you have to
pay those transmission fees versus
something in New Hampshire that's ever
so slightly more expensive but there's
all of the economic development benefit
of having chosen that contract under the
existing language I'm not certain that
that folks putting in their proposals
would be able to make the argument that
their project should be chosen based on
that economic Economic Development
representative Reynolds has a question
thank you Mr chairman
um Sam I I liked this bill a lot better
when it was in the Senate and it was
aimed you know laser focused on
incentivizing renewable development and
you know because it recognized the
conundrum or you know the situation you
point out in your testimony about
Capital costs being a much higher
fraction of overall cost do you
um
do you see danger in in the fact that
you know I understand the principles of
fuel neutrality but do you think it's
dangerous that in sort of leveling the
playing field so to speak in this
um version of the bill
that we are
um risking the kind of dangers that the
the power generators Association spoke
to
so uh for the record I did not write the
amendment that you have in front of you
and and if if I had written it it would
it would likely be somewhat different
um the reason that clean energy hamster
is comfortable supporting this
legislation is is that again if you look
at the iso New England interconnection
queue
um I used to say that it was 95
renewable energy and batteries uh but
then we got an update at the iso New
England consumer liaison group and we're
now up to 98 uh renewable energy and
batteries that are that are the projects
that are being proposed on the Queue my
understanding is that there's a single
natural gas plant being proposed in in
Peabody Massachusetts and that's the
only fossil resource that folks have put
in uh so as such the fact that this is
for new resources only
um you know again it's not the bill that
I would have written but but it's it it
makes me substantially more comfortable
with with supporting it
um now that said uh there's a number
there's a number of like who knows how
this will go uh so so everything that's
in this bill is is sort of
um voluntary right so the the contracts
can be up to 20 years
um and and that so that it may be that
that uh that I will be surprised
um and and that that we will see fossil
resources bidding into this
um in a very competitive way I I guess
I'm I just struggle to understand how a
resource that has a variable fuel cost
can uh can put in a a price that is that
is stable and and know that they'll make
their money back
um and and so again that's that's where
a modicum of my comfort with this bill
comes from
representative Harrington has a question
thank you Mr chairman Ling for taking my
question I have a question and a
clarification let's start with the
clarification you gave an example of a
project up in Maine and it would be
transmission costs associated with that
but looking on page uh I guess it's one
of the bill it says any costs associated
with transmission system upgrades
required for interconnecting new or
incremental electric sources shall be
included in responses to the proposals
so there would be no addition that would
be part of the price already included
right and and so so I was simply
throwing it out there because maybe
you've got something that's got a better
resource but a longer transmission path
and you know as perhaps giving too many
details now my question if I follow up
uh in your letter on the last it's the
last page uh in your bullet two I'm
trying to figure this out a little bit
you say you talk about how this could
affect
um
Community power Market which I
understand because there's a
non-bypassable charge that they could
face if the electricity was sold into
the market but then you say uh we
believe it's best by addressing this by
assisting the utility shall reconcile
the cost of these contracts through
distribution rates which is on page 313
and I don't I just don't understand how
that's going to solve the problem if
they still can do a non-bypassable
charge where someone that has Community
power or competitive power supply is
going to pay for electricity that they
don't have anything to do with
so
um Community power I believe Community
power is here and has put in a pink card
to testify so so they could speak to
this but but my my sort of top level
understanding of this is that uh there's
a concern that the utilities would be
able to sort of Arbitrage back and forth
between default recovering the these
contracts through default service or
non-by-passable charge depending on what
the market conditions are unless that
that may becomes a show
um if that may becomes a shell it this
just becomes a policy decision that the
state has made that all rate payers are
are
um you know stuck with more or less be
it in the money or out of the money
um and uh and there's not a concern that
the utilities would use it sort of
preferentially to to compete against
um since you already asked a couple of
questions is it okay if we move on or is
okay
see no more questions for Mr Sam Evans
Brown I will move on next to
Mr Henry Herndon from the community
power Coalition of New Hampshire
and the community power Coalition
opposes this bill so we'll be interested
to understand why thank you
thank you Mr chair thank you committee
um
I'm Henry Herndon I'm here on behalf of
the community power Coalition of New
Hampshire and uh board chair of the
Coalition Clifton below sends his
regrets but he has a written two paid
more one page front and back
um testimony that has been circulated to
the committee so I'll keep my comments
brief I think many of the the points
that I hopes to raise have already been
addressed I know it's a long day for the
committee
um but yes the the community power
Coalition of New Hampshire opposes this
bill this is a joint Powers agency of uh
34 cities towns and counties that have
joined together to make use of the
community power legislation and access
the competitive market to achieve I
think many of the objectives that are
put forth uh in this bill
um so I don't think there's necessarily
a disagreement on we want to effectively
lower electricity costs but there's a
disagreement on what is the the best way
to do that
um and
yeah I'll just reiterate really quickly
and then take committee's question the
committee's questions but um
you know this really is a coin flip for
the next 20 years of whether or not
there will be benefits and there's
uncertainty to the degree to what those
benefits would be they are unknowable
um and there is potential for a massive
cost shift onto competitive market
actors so folks who shop for competitive
Supply and this was addressed by
representative Harrington and others and
folks who are on the community power
would pay for the cost of these assets
through a non-by-passable charge in the
increase in distribution rates to the
extent that they're
um they are charged as described in the
legislation and that is the primary
reason for the coalition's objection to
this legislation
um
and
I'll just sort of note
um you know the the concerns are valid
but again the gentleman from the New
England power generators Association uh
really articulated this well
um
we are at this uh particular moment in
the market where we were coming out of a
particularly high cost event uh for
utility default Supply and I would
encourage the committee not to sort of
lose our lose our heads and because of
that brief uh event uh make a change it
would dramatically affect the New
Hampshire's competitive Electric market
for 20 years to come
um and I think that there are ways that
we can as the gentleman over here
actually suggested incentivize Market
actors to do this exact thing uh the
gentleman from clean energy New
Hampshire alluded to this as well we can
create Market mechanisms to incentivize
the development of new generation
resources in the state of New Hampshire
that achieve this purpose Without Really
you know giving a blank check to
Monopoly utilities to to enter into
these long-term contracts so I would I
would encourage the committee to really
look hard at how do we find market-based
solutions to do this exact thing to
achieve this exact thing
without sort of reintroducing the the
monopolization of the con the supply
Marketplace
um
and yeah with that I'll close my
comments and I'll take any questions if
there are any thank you
perfect thank you questions for the
committee representative munz has one
thank you very much thank you for coming
in here
um can you can you share any thoughts
you might have about some of those
market-based solutions that would
encourage development
yes
um I think there's a particular
opportunity at the sort of intrastate
wholesale level the one to five megawatt
level
um and I know this isn't a hearing on
Senate Bill 166 but that was discussed
last week I understand there's a work
session this afternoon uh and there may
be some amendments or creative ways to
improve that bill uh that could achieve
exactly this to basically allow Market
actors to develop projects that reduce
certain elements of the cost stack
transmission costs capacity costs other
wholesale costs and you allow the Public
Utility Commission to
calculate that value and then create a
fair Level Playing Field where utilities
could propose projects that lower those
costs Market actors could propose
projects that lower those costs and now
we have sort of robust local marketplace
where folks are developing new resources
which I think is the intent of this bill
but they're doing it under a market
structure as opposed to
um the this approach
follow-up follow-up
are there are there any do you have it
do you are there any
um limitations that you have right now
that are preventing your organization
and other community power organizations
from
encouraging new development and is there
anything that we should be doing to
enable you to to do that let's keep our
questions confined to the subject of the
bill okay fine thank you
representative McGee has a question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you Mr
Herndon for taking my question
um my thoughts are were along the line
of
the recent testimony yours and the one
that preceded you bring to mind growing
pains right the the point was brought up
that we're in a transition and so people
are trying to figure out do we do things
the way we've always done them do we
borrow things from other states
um and so I I wonder if you could
comment on the fact uh of maybe where
the community power Coalition is at this
point in time because I think we just
enabled that and I feel like maybe in
some ways this would be pulling the rug
out from under
um the point that they're at in terms of
moving forward to figure out what the
price signals are in the market
in a sense yes it would be it would be
at least introducing an unfairness or an
imbalance in the market
um that would limit the the ability of
competitive actors like the coalition to
to fully deliver benefits and you know
we talk about who has the the uh
the ability to finance these types of
projects and today Community power
Coalition may not be able to do that
today but
um you know we have the policies in the
business uh structure in place to very
quickly over the next few years develop
our financial reserves register as a
market participant with ISO New England
um and then be be sort of financially
sufficient to finance those at low cost
ourselves so we this is one example of
them of a market actor that could do
that in a few short years and um so I
representative Kaplan has a question
thank you Mr chair and uh thank you for
coming in today and taking my question
um
we've had discussion about the the shift
in the marketplace and the transition to
a new uh Market design and
the need to decarbonize our electricity
system and so the bill that we have in
front of us is contemplating a fairly
ambitious shift to you know one-fifth of
the entire load
um and I understand that that has
impacts obviously on all the players in
the market uh including your your type
of organization but um do you excuse me
could you move a little closer yeah do
you have any idea what uh percentage you
know going out 10 years from now what
percentage of
generating capacity Community power
structures could provide and would that
be anything akin to what we're looking
at here which is you know one-fifth of
the load I cannot say that for a
certainty um and that is in part because
the objective of the Coalition is not
explicitly to develop a certain kind of
resource it is to serve the objectives
of its member cities and towns some of
those cities and towns have very strong
renewable energy goals
um there are a number of them that do so
for those towns the Coalition can meet
those needs by Contracting with
renewable sources and to this extent
that it is cost effective we'll do that
for the portfolio as a whole so we are
looking at that holistically I can't say
specifically right now at what point the
coalition's portfolio will be what
okay see no further questions from the
committee we'll move along only five
speakers stand between us and lunch and
the next of those speakers will be
Kristen Koch from the business and
good morning and welcome
good morning Mr chair and members of the
committee is it still morning it's a
pleasure to be here today
um Kirsten Koch representing the
business and industry Association also
known as Bia
we are here today in support of Senate
Bill 54 Granite State businesses
desperately need relief from high energy
costs and we believe that at this time
New Hampshire should be using every tool
in its toolbox to lower the cost of
energy
Senate Bill 54 is a market-driven energy
procurement process that prioritizes
cost savings and reliability in an
Innovative way to increase in-state
energy production in a manner that would
lower energy costs for rate pairs we
believe that this bill is perhaps the
only Bill remaining this session that
proactively seeks to lower energy costs
for ratepayers so we think it's
significant for the legislation
legislature to take action on this bill
I want to note that Senate Bill 54 as
amended has bipartisan support and is
the product of input from a variety of
key stakeholders we've worked
pain-sakenly to get input from a variety
of folks working together on this
compromise and we're really proud of of
the variety of stakeholders that have
come together to make this work and who
are looking for a solution for New
Hampshire
um it's essential to us that the primary
benefit and outcome achieved here
through this process is lowering energy
costs and providing benefits for rate
Pairs and although it comes with a
multitude of benefits including Economic
Development potential local tax revenue
and environmental benefits we see this
bill as having the proper safeguards to
um I do want to comment on some of the
changes that Sam Evans Brown proposed
were in support of those we we think
it's important to have that local
benefit Edition
um to to keep those projects and jobs
here we're also supportive of changes
that would require that the utilities
instead of May it should say Xiao on
page 3 line 13
which would require that the utilities
shall sell purchase energy and
environmental attributes into the
wholesale Market in a manner to minimize
cost and maximize benefits to rate pairs
we see this change as addressing some of
the concerns of the competitive
generators or the community power
Coalition because this would ensure that
the manner in which the utilities can
sell energy and environmental attributes
gained from these projects and contracts
will not negatively impact these folks
so we do find that that change is
important to addressing those concerns
but ultimately
we were effectively also this committee
passed Senate bill 54. it's an
Innovative way to lower energy costs and
you know there's ample evidence that the
current market is not operating and
producing outcomes that are cost
effective are reliable for ratepayers so
thank you for your consideration I'm
happy to try to answer any questions the
committee may have
thank you very much questions from the
committee representative Harrington has
one
um thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um I'm a little
confused because I believe I'm correct
in saying that the overwhelming majority
of the Bia members buy their power on
the competitive market they don't take
the fault Service rates so since this
would have no effect or extremely little
effect on any rates other than default
service other than the fact of that
non-bypassable charge that people take
competitive rates would now have to
could pay why you think it's going to
lower rates for people that don't take
the fault service
well thank you for the question
representative and I think maybe there's
a misunderstanding some of our large
manufacturers do use competitive Supply
but not entirely and we have a variety
of members of large and small businesses
who this does affect I mean it's not a
majority of our members are not on
competitive Supply and it is important
to them to lower energy costs we hear
from you know members who are small
businesses members who have
manufacturing just in New Hampshire
those smaller businesses this is really
important to change for them
follow up but there's nothing for those
members that choose to take default
Service rates from switching to a
competitive supplier and is there
anything that you know of because some
of these uh business uh members of your
organization may be power suppliers that
nothing prevents these power suppliers
from entering in long-term contracts
with competitive suppliers is there
I don't believe there's anything
stopping them from doing competitive
Supply but this just provides an
alternative
additional questions representative
Reynolds has one
thank you Mr chairman and uh thank you
Miss Koch for being here I'm intrigued
by your suggestion that uh if I heard
you correctly you
suggested that in on the very last page
of the bill section four that rather
than
um allowing
the inve the utilities
to sell
the purchase energy sell the the product
of these pbas rather than just allowing
them to sell it into the wholesale
Market that they shall sell it into the
whole team Market which seems like it
would sort of radically change what this
what the
well how the bill would work it would it
would make the investor own utilities
sort of
agents of
Contracting for a lot for new new
long-term energy resources
and I guess
um can you expound a little bit more on
that recommendation the rationale uh
yeah sure and I think that
um thank you for the question I think
there's some folks who are who are
better experts who can go into detail on
that but our thoughts is that that would
alleviate some of the community power
Coalition concerns about you know the
costs and taking away from their efforts
you know we don't want to undermine
their efforts that's not the point of
this bill
thank you
further questions for Miss Koch
seeing none we want to thank you for
being here to testify and we'll call
next on Meredith Hatfield of The Nature
thank you chairman Vos members of the
committee Meredith Hatfield for the
nature conservancy and we unfortunately
do oppose this bill as amended by the
Senate as much as we very much would
like to support it we did support it as
introduced for three reasons at that
time it was for
um clean energy resources only
secondly it was very targeted at solving
part of the default service price
increases that we've seen unfortunately
we don't think this version does that
and then thirdly
um actually very related to the
conversation that representative
Reynolds was just having about the
non-by-passable charge
um we're concerned that the utilities
would take advantage of that language on
page three that's currently May
um
to resell the power which is exactly
what's happening with Berlin biomass
plant right now which is going to strain
at costs for customers so we don't
support the bill as amended and we think
that if as some prior speakers have
testified
that you want this to absolutely result
in the lowest cost and to result in
price suppression then those words
should be in the bill so in this section
of the bill that directs the puc what it
should look at in its review so this is
um
starting right on line one on page three
we do have the words cost effective
but if you want lowest price and you
want price oppression it probably would
be more clear direction to the puc to
put those
um those actual words right in the bill
and then I would just I also wanted to
remind you which I'm sure you remember
that you retained House Bill 159 which
is a much more targeted Bill looking at
how to address the default service
prices that we've been seeing and I also
just wanted to mention the puc does have
an open docket looking at that and you
all have mentioned you know how
complicated this is and that laddering
or other approaches might be better
um to reduce rates in the short term and
and we think those are better that the
puc and a bill very targeted on default
service might be better ways to address
costs uh in the short term
thank you
thank you thank you Meredith for your
testimony do I have any questions here
representative
Kaplan your question
thank you Mr chair and uh
does your organization uh not support
the aim of trying to increase the amount
of Renewable Power in our generation
load and and would you you know would
you agree that this bill might go some
way towards doing that
yes thank you for the question and and
that's actually why we supported the
original version which was an amendment
um to the RPS law itself so that it was
very targeted to try to increase the
amount of renewable energy that would be
cited in New Hampshire and would be used
by New Hampshire customers
um this bill could result in
um us benefiting from new Renewables and
as Sam Evans Brown pointed out most of
the iso Q is Renewables but
um because of the way it's structured it
it quite likely won't reduce costs and
could increase stranded costs so we we
seeing no other questions thank you so
much for your testimony always a
pleasure to see you
and I'm going to call on Lindsay
burgnoring
all right
thank you chair Thomas again Lindsey
Bruin from revision energy
um as members of clean energy New
Hampshire we Echo their testimony and we
are here today in support of the bill
um we would respectfully like to add um
just a note and a caution that given the
size of the aggregate annual cap
um within this bill utilities will
likely be encouraged to favor sizable
resources that may not deliver the
benefits of added clean energy or local
investment rate here in New Hampshire as
you've heard a few speakers
um speak to procuring large-scale hydro
or offshore wind would surely have both
public health and climate mitigation
impacts but does little for direct
impact on New Hampshire's economy and
the creation of local jobs so for that
reason we recommend amending the bill to
expand criteria to prioritize in-state
generation and we would be happy to
share sample language in this regard
with the committee that could be
included in section one and section two
and with that I know I'm standing in
between you all and sandwiches so I'll
leave it there
thank you do you have written testimony
that you could give us to to summarize
that position because I'm like not
likely to remember what you said
absolutely uh questions from the
committee representative Harrington has
one uh thank you thank you for taking my
question I'm so if I understand what
you're saying correctly you think that
the rate payers should pay a higher rate
uh in order to keep the uh procurement
uh from a plant that's in New Hampshire
as compared to being in Maine
I think there should be an opportunity
for for everything to compete
so I would freeze it okay follow-up
follow-up yeah I'm a little confused
okay so I have a plant in in New
Hampshire and a proposed plant New
Hampshire proposed plant in Maine they
both put in contracts the one in Maine
comes in lower you're saying we should
give preference to the one in New
Hampshire anyways because it's in New
Hampshire even though it'll cost rate
payers more I think there should be
consideration language in the bill so
that the direct um investment in New
Hampshire's economy could be considered
alongside the additional criteria
I'd love to see how that would be
written out thank you
okay further questions from the
committee
seeing that I want to thank you Miss
Burgoyne for being here and call next on
Michael Licata from eversource to give
us his perspective on this proposed
legislation
after Mr locata tells us uh gives us his
perspective then we'll have one more
speaker and then we'll be done for
um
the day hopefully on this bill
uh for the record Michael Licata
eversource energy uh I was worried I was
gonna be the last person between you and
lunch so
happy to hear that there's one more
um
eversource is uh supportive of uh Senate
Bill 54. I just want to say that we
really do appreciate the hard work of
the bill sponsor Senator avard Senator
Waters uh the Bia and other stakeholders
to try to come together and as you can
see there's a lot of different
perspectives and competing interests to
try to thread that needle and present
you with a good bill that advances an
important public policy priority I just
want to walk through just a couple of
numbers that I think might be helpful
for why this bill is in front of you
um and I'll start with a topic that's
come up a few times which is uh the
issues that were experienced on
Christmas Eve uh
2816 dollars
that was the locational marginal price
Peak on Christmas Eve uh per megawatt to
put that in perspective right now it's
kind of a cool rainy day the LMP for New
England is around 35 dollars
that was the price that uh the market
was producing on Christmas Eve because
we did not have enough adequate supply
of low-cost reliable sources of energy
5000 megawatts
that is the number that ISO New England
has stated is at risk of retirement in
the next year or two
five thousand megawatts of Base load
power that needs to be replaced in order
to continue a reliable Regional energy
grid
and I ask you all to consider where that
1413. that's the number of megawatts
that Mystic station in Everett
Massachusetts produces it's a natural
gas plant that is only operating because
of an out of Market contract a
reliability must run contract that is
keeping it in business only until May of
2024 and again I asked the committee to
consider where the megawatts will come
we have a demand problem in New England
and we have a supply problem in New
England and I apologize if that's
repetitive because I have testified to
it a number of times we do not have
enough reliable low-cost sources of
electricity to meet the demand
the very best public policy is that this
committee can pursue is reducing demand
and increasing Supply
as it stands today before that
additional 5 000 megawatts of retirement
as evidenced by Christmas Eve we are
having a very difficult time
meeting demand and keeping the lights on
the bill before you is a reasonable and
I would actually say modest step to
address this issue
2 million megawatt hours may sound like
a lot it is not 20 percent that grows
each year it is a fixed number
you have heard from
uh renewable developers who have told
you that in order to get financing to
build new projects they require
long-term certainty
this bill enables utilities to offer
that long-term certainty in order to
build new resources to replace retiring
existing resources
it is a technology
neutral procurement that is focused on
cost and reliability
there has been much discussion of other
procurements in other states and the
outcomes that they have produced
I would submit to you those other
procurements in all five other New
England states that have occurred
have been focused on very specific
Technologies
procure offshore wind
support existing nuclear
the utilities that ran those
procurements
are not debating whether or not they
would lower cost when entering into
those contracts and submitting them for
approval they were determining which is
the lowest cost offshore wind contract
available because that state and many of
them have done this have had a public
policy directive to enter into contracts
for long-term wind
I submit that is not what this bill does
this bill is enabling the utilities to
issue a competitive
uh solicitation to get back low-cost
reliable sources of energy
it is a different approach I would
submit is a New Hampshire approach to
try to address this issue and as the
department of energy said try to build
new things new sources of supply
there's been a lot of talk about risk
associated with the bill and there is
risk there is no doubt no one has a
crystal ball six months two years 20
years however I would submit to you
there is a risk in inaction
your customer our customers your
constituents are paying that risk today
in their electric rates
it is very clear and appropriate that
these suppliers that bid back for
default service are building in Risk
they are not taking that risk they are
building that risk into the bids that
they offer back to utilities customers
are paying that risk today
they will continue to pay that risk
until we solve this issue of wintertime
pricing which is reliant on natural gas
there's been a lot of discussion about
the Burgess biomass contract I think Mr
Evans Brown did a good job describing
the differences between
this approach and that power purchase
agreement which was quite frankly
specifically targeted to support a
biomass plant in Berlin New Hampshire to
address issues of economic development
that occurred when a paper mill closed
this is a very different approach
I would submit to you that uh I think Mr
Reynolds representative Reynolds uh
described this well that the utilities
are facilitating the financial
transaction under this bill
it is not as you heard previously
rolling back restructuring allowing
vertically integrated utilities the
utilities own nothing under this bill we
will competitively procure the best
lowest cost responses back third parties
will enter into agreements they will
secure financing they will take risk if
they cannot meet the requirements and
the the terms of those contracts and the
utility uh will not be constructing uh
I know you've had a lot of information
thrown at you I would be very happy to
answer any questions that I can
thank you I'd be curious to know how a
utility would respond to a question that
was asked earlier about whether
utility investors should share some of
the risk
rather than placing it all on the back
of utility rate payers
what's your what's your take on that
question so so there have been
regulatory mechanisms uh in other
jurisdictions that uh as representative
Harrington said reward the utility when
they save money and charge the utility
when they uh if if they miss the Mark I
would suggest to you those were
um uh regulatory mechanisms that were
around the construction of projects
where the utilities have some control
over the costs associated with those
projects here it is a third party that
is is doing the project we are going to
enter into uh we are going to solicit
the lowest cost we're going to to do an
analysis uh that will be submitted to
the Public Utilities Commission and at
that point in time be deemed in the
public interest
because the utility does not have
control over the responses it receives
or control over the costs associated
with the the construction of that
project
it would put the utility in an untenable
position where we're taking on risk that
So you're satisfied that utility rate
payers who have no way to mitigate those
costs take on all those risks I I think
that utility rate payers uh and this is
true of of all states benefit from the
development of additional resources
whether they take utility default
service or not
competitive customers who take
competitive Supply customers who are on
Community power aggregation
all benefit from the development of
additional low-cost resources in fact Mr
Dolan on behalf of nepka stated that in
his testimony their concern with the
bill
is that lower cost uh generation will be
bid into the iso Market pushing out
higher cost generation that simply can't
compete
resulting in lower costs which obviously
is bad for incumbent generators I
recognize that but is in fact good for
consumers everyone benefits from that
whether they're on default service or
not
okay additional questions from the
committee representative Harrington has
one thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question uh I'm just trying to
get a feel for the market on this I mean
everyone's talking about that no one's
going to build without a PPA which I
think everyone agrees with you simply
doesn't get done
but there are many other sources of ppas
other than a regulated utility there's a
lot of private contractors I know for
example uh Starbucks or one of those
other coffee places does it Whole Foods
does it there's billions of dollars of
federal subsidies out there and huge
amounts of tax credits that these
companies get yet it appears even though
we're building wind utility scale wind
and solar all over the country no one's
doing it in New England and specifically
no one's doing it in New Hampshire what
is it about our markets here that make
it so unpopular for people to willingly
invest their money in power plants here
so I I would suggest that uh utility
scale solar is being built in New
England and it is being built because
other states have done competitive
solicitations to enter into Power
purchase agreements for for those
resources that Contracting is going on I
I think the question you're asking me is
you know why aren't corporations uh
investing in in this although I I guess
if the question is why isn't that
happening in New Hampshire
because we aren't doing competitive
solicitations for for uh projects
we don't have this Authority in law
today or it is unclear that utilities
could could provide that long-term
certainty to make those projects happen
what we do see is in New Hampshire is
much smaller projects usually uh uh
purchase power agreements with
municipalities that end up getting very
small uh or smaller solar installations
and Mr Herndon talked about the the one
to five megawatts
if you have 5 000 uh megawatts of
generation that's going to be retiring
that's a lot of solar projects that are
uh additional questions representative
uh Wendy Thomas
thank you Mr chair uh thank you for
being here and and giving some um good
information uh would you be okay we've
had a lot of discussion about May and
Chao uh are you comfortable with
changing uh the May to a shell for
public comment and the May to a shell
for reconciling the cost of the
contracts through uh distribution rates
yes okay to both thank you
represent representative Summers has a
question
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question this is actually
going to tie back to a question I asked
earlier an earlier testimony about would
this bill as written give the utilities
capability
or the opportunity and capability to let
not only ladder but also to be able to
go back to the market more often than
just once every six months
this bill would not that that is not the
focus of this this legislation
representative munz has a question thank
you Mr chair and thank you again for
being here
um and thank you for
um
characterizing I think correctly the
role of the utility is basically a a
financing facilitator and if I'm
incorrect then please correct me and if
if that is in fact the case which I
think it is then
um I I think it does make sense that the
utility should be protected from risk
because you're just providing a service
but isn't it true that there would be
another alternative
and I'm not saying that it's something
that we would want to pursue but the
other alternative would be for the state
to just be that credit worthy party
um and and then if if that happened the
state would be assuming the risk and the
taxpayers would be assuming the risk
correct
that is correct and other states have
done procurements that were run by the
state I think that is correct thank you
additional questions representative
Reynolds has one thank you Mr chairman
um yeah I just wanted to clarify you you
may have answered this already from
representative Thomas question but I I
want to be sure did you mean I was going
to ask you about the
how you felt about the bia's suggestion
that
changing that may to shall which would
essentially make the utility a facility
a pass-through
and and not allow the utility to sort of
straddle the the market and and compete
against the competitive suppliers
is that is that what you meant that that
is correct and I would say that that is
uh the treatment of uh
the law energy procured through
long-term contracts and other
jurisdictions some that eversource
operates in and others that we do not
that is consistent uh it is not to
disrupt the competitive Marketplace the
competitive uh you know folks are free
to
um uh enter into agreements with
competitive suppliers uh and it is a a
flow through uh that customers ideally
uh and we do have uh uh you know
examples of this received the benefit
from not only from the development of
new resources but receive the benefit
from of a reduction a credit uh because
the the uh the market price is higher
than what the utility is selling into
the the market so that that Delta ends
okay representative McGee has a question
thank you Mr chair I was hedging back
and forth whether I'd ask this or not
um so uh what I'm hearing is that
um we're trying to solve
several issues have come up that it
appears we're trying to solve several
bites at the Apple here
um
this bill is is looking to bring price
stability
um looking to be agnostic in terms of
what type of fuel
but you also brought up the numbers at
the beginning of your testimony stating
that part of the problem is that base
load sources are rolling Off the Grid
and although that is a something we
should have a plan around in terms of
how we're going to deal with it it also
makes it seem like we're going to solve
for that when in reality isn't it the
grid operator's responsibility to make
sure that there's adequate
dispatchable Supply
the iso New England's role is to to
manage uh the wholesale
generation system and transmission
system
they can't
make people build things
they can as they are with Mystic station
keeping a at-risk facility online for a
limited amount of time does this bill
solve all of the Region's reliability
Pro problems absolutely not as I said 2
million megawatts uh is is a relatively
small amount
but it is a step
it is an important step
it gives the utilities another tool in
the toolbox as you heard previously it
is enabling this is not a mandate and so
yes it is the iso's job to quote unquote
keep the lights on
um however
they're Limited in in what they can do
and so I think a a you know this was
described as one piece of the puzzle I
think by the department of energy
um ISO has been saying pretty loudly for
a number of years that they see a train
crash coming
and so you know if they were able to
incent the development or or of new
resources I'm sure they would be doing
everything they can to make sure the
resources are there and I'm sure they
are
okay
so you know further questions from the
committee I want to thank you and call
our last speaker on this bill that's
Mark Brown from the consumer energy
good afternoon and welcome
all right
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee
for the record my name is Mark Brown I
am vice president state affairs for
Consumer Energy Alliance on behalf of CA
I want to thank you for the opportunity
to provide this testimony in support of
Senate bill 54.
we've heard a lot of talk today about
you know volatility volatility in energy
markets uh that's not just restrained to
the New England area it's uh nationally
and globally as well
I think the geopolitical turmoil is
probably not going away anytime soon one
of the problems I would say with what's
going on is New England we have a what
is a single uniform clearing price in
our energy markets that means that the
whoever clears the stack is the marginal
unit every unit below that gets paid
whatever that clearing price is
and as everybody knows we are relatively
Supply constraint when it comes to
natural gas you know in the winter time
and about 70 percent of the time natural
gas generators are the marginal unit
there
um so that's probably not going to
change anytime soon we're going to
continue to see increased electricity
demand as we continue to Electrify the
transportation and heating sectors of
our economy
but touching on that I want to you know
talk about what's kind of happening you
know nationally so right now there's
about 30 billion cubic feet a day of LNG
export capacity being built
it's been ferc approved and it's in the
pipeline to to be built now we produce
about 100 BCF a day which is we're at
record levels of natural gas production
so what that means is we're we're lined
up to export 30 of our current
production of natural gas
so the volatility volatility in Newlands
natural gas markets that's not going to
change that's not going to change
anytime soon and we're going to continue
to need those natural gas plants for the
if New Hampshire was alone on an island
perhaps that we you know we maybe we
wouldn't be as subject to that type of
volatility but we are part of a regional
grid and we are subject to other states
policies and we have to kind of play in
that sandboard sandbox to some extent
we view Senate Bill 54 as an opportunity
to provide a hedge against the existing
volatility in energy markets
um and what I'll say is you know there
are two states that have the last five
years that have had substantially lower
prices than the rest of the region
um that's Vermont which remains
vertically integrated I don't believe
their utilities own a whole lot of
generation if any but they have they
purchased their power through a series
of bilateral contracts one of those
contracts is for about 25 percent of
their power from Hydro Quebec which I
think is a 25 or 26 year contract
so for the last five years Vermont has
had either the lowest electricity rates
in the region or the second lowest rates
in the region the other state that has
had substantially lower rates is Maine
which has a kind of an interconnection
the northern part of the state connects
to New Brunswick and uh that probably
provides some hedge against volatility
volatility of New England's markets
so what I would say is I guess from a
consumer perspective we can sit here and
we could talk about markets markets
markets I think ideologically I'm a huge
supporter of markets but the bottom line
is those markets are not delivering
um affordable power to our consumers
um
you know I I think you know if you're
looking at right now
Vermont and New Hampshire there's a 10
cent per kilowatt hour cost differential
between the two states
um now that may not last but right now
10 cents a kilowatt hour is a lot of
that's a lot of juice that's a lot of
money if you look at just a one kilowatt
one cent per kilowatt hour difference
you're looking at about a 35 million
dollar you know savings so to speak so
if New Hampshire could lower its default
Service rates by one cent you know with
its load you'd be looking at 35 million
dollar a year in savings so um this is
not a mandate as has been repeated it's
going to be it would be a competitive
solicitation
um and as I mentioned previously we are
going to see increased demand for
electricity from the further
electrification of the heating and
transportation sectors and where is that
power going to come from so with that
I'll be happy to and oh one other thing
representative Harrington I want to take
a stab at answering your question
earlier about competitive suppliers and
you know why don't they enter into
long-term contracts they may we don't
know that information is at the trading
desk and it's not publicly available so
they may very well be hedging part of
their portfolio with longer term
contracts
they just aren't subject to regulation
by the state that prohibits them from
doing so so they may not be but they
very well could be we just don't know
so with that I'll be happy to take any
questions
great thank you for that Illuminating
testimony representative Kaplan has a
question thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my my question
um
I'm just curious where your organization
sees any new generation capacity coming
from to cover that hedge that you
mentioned where do you see that
generation we don't have interconnection
to uh New Brunswick or right right so
where would you see it coming from well
if you look at the iso New England queue
as Sam Evans Brown stated earlier you
know it's all wind solar and storage
um he's right I think the only fossil
generation that's in the queue is a 50
megawatt gas plant that's going to be um
put into in Peabody and I'm sure that's
going to be used to you know as a as a
peaking unit to offset you know
renewable energy load you know for the
most part
um and I would add Hydra to that you
know you could possibly procure some
some generation from Hydro Quebec I
don't see any fossil fuel development
you know in New Hampshire or beyond that
50 megawatt plant in Peabody occurring
in New England we don't have the
okay additional questions for Mr Brown
seeing that I want to thank you for your
testimony and since I have no more pink
cards I'll ask representative closure
before I wrap up business here to give
us the uh
the count totals of support and
non-support for these three bills that
we've heard here this morning so
representative closure what's the what's
it look like
it's thanking Mr chair uh Senate Bill
the blue sheet shows one in support
none opposed
the online 19 is support not opposed
and Senate bill
by 52 blue sheep was one in support none
opposed
thank you blue sheet
two and support one oppose
online it was 26 in support
131 oppose and one new show and Mr chair
testimony online from Monday April 10th
if you'd like
you mean statistics from online
sure go ahead and read it sorry about
Senate Bill 113
the blue sheep
eight in support
none opposed
online 49 in support none opposed
Senate bill 161.
the blue sheet or in support
none of polls online 16
in support six opposed
Senate Bill 166
the blue sheet
six
in support
none opposed
online 106
support
nine opposed
Senate Bill 167
the blue sheet
six in support
none opposed
online
12 support
12 opposed two neutral thank you Mr
chair
thank you representative closure so
we're going to close the public hearing
on Senate bill 54.
and I will now go over how we're going
to proceed for the rest of the day since
it is just about quarter of one
I'm going to ask everybody in this room
who is not a member of this committee on
the Republican side to exit at your
earliest and quickest convenience as the
Republicans will caucus
from now until 1 15 then we will go to
lunch at 1 15 until 2 o'clock and we
will come back here at two o'clock for a
work session on all of these Senate
bills
so for those of you who are not members
of the Republican members of this
committee we'll see you back here at two
o'clock everybody else
okay good afternoon everybody let's take
our seats and uh let's uh open a full
committee work session on the 12 Senate
bills that we will be exacting tomorrow
now representative McGee and I have
already had a meeting about these 12
bills we have a general sense of what
our respective caucuses would like to do
with these bills
but of course
uh individual
conversations can change that consensus
so we'll have to see during the course
of our discussions here this afternoon
just exactly where we are
we think we know where we are but we're
not sure
so anyway what I'd like to do is I'd
like to go through each of these bills
and have a a general discussion
we'll try to make it as quick as
possible so we can get out of here
before midnight
and uh
and then just go from there so let's
start with Senate Bill 16. I'd like to
do these in order
apparently there's still
um testimony
circulating from
a little bit of a
little little bit of a paperwork
52-54 so let's go back to uh Senate Bill
16 which establishes a stakeholder group
to address utility polls and attachments
in New Hampshire
anybody have anything they would like to
representative Harrington
this has been a problem and an issue for
I'm aware for at least 20 years and I'm
sure it goes on much longer than that so
anything we can do to fix this let's go
for it
further discussion representative Doug
Thomas
I agree with the uh representative I I'm
representative Wendy Thomas no I I'm
just going to say this is a no-brainer
yeah
okay
um
it has been suggested to me that a
Sunset date might be appropriate for
this legislation anybody have any
of us on set date
the way the bill is worded this uh the
advisory committee that's established
by this
legislation would
never
end it would just go on forever
filing reports Etc somebody suggested it
might be worthwhile to to Sunset
after some period of time
so I was just trying to get a sense of
whether anybody thought that was a good
idea a bad idea don't care I think it's
a good idea
representative McWilliams
intention of the bill is to come to some
conclusions and recommendations
I would say that it may make sense to
Sunset that still
spifter six years or when a final
conclusion report has been issued
addressing all of the topics something
like that
okay that's a good idea
while seeing none
I will uh later today I will
ask OLS to create an amendment to this
bill to add a Sunset date you suggested
five six years would five years be okay
just as a more round number
I just wanted to conclude when we
normally issue reports so if it's the
end of a term you know or two-year
legislative period okay I'll look at
that yeah
I'll do what seems to make sense
okay anything else on 16.
let's go to SB 40.
now I sent you via email an amendment to
sb40
I think I sent it out on Friday
there's new language in there that
that
lengthens the arms of the straitjacket
that this bill puts around the
definition of customer generator so that
the only two projects in the in the
entire world that this could apply to
would be Monadnock paper and Brookfield
Hydro
and we feel I feel relatively confident
that that this bill now accomplishes
everything
that we wanted to accomplish without
unforeseen circumstance that's going to
destroy the world so uh
anybody else have any comment on that
representative Wendy Thomas thank you I
wasn't here when they had the hearing
for this but in your your description
right now you say that this bill is
again it's just for two companies
and we had a the Burgess Bill recently
that was just for one company I just are
we in the business now of creating bills
specifically for specific companies
I would say no we're in the business of
addressing
problems that appla that might apply to
one or two companies in the case of
these two Hydro facilities they were
wired
dozens of years ago decades ago in such
a way that uh
we would they would never be wired that
way today it's a it's a legacy
Antiquated way of wiring up uh these
interconnections and
they were never changed it's too
expensive to rewire them from the way
they were originally wired
and uh so the only way to fix that is to
write legislation that applies to these
Legacy problems and fixes them
so when I said this only applied to
Monadnock paper and Brookfield I didn't
really mean that it only applies to
those two companies I mean it applies to
their unique dilemma which is the way
they are wired or interconnected to
any further comment on sb40
representative munz I just had a had a
question I know there was some
discussion during the um
testimony we received about what what
might happen if
um the paper mill goes on goes out of
business
does that does that does does your
Amendment address that or does it need
to address it
no the amendment does not address that
that's a PPA question and we asked the
two companies
involved Brookfield and White Mountain
paper to
discuss between themselves
how they would address that and they'd
if it informed us that they've come up
with a uh agreeable
compromised resolution
to their uh existing
arrangement
represented I mean Mr kuzzy do you have
anything to add to that
why don't you come up to the microphone
thank you Mr chairman appreciate the
Indulgence uh representative uh
in the event that the mill were to cease
operations the owner of the mill uh
would still be the utility customer of
record
uh that and they they would still be
they would still need uh some
electricity just to make sure the the
buildings don't go into some semblance
of disrepair things along those lines so
even if there's no operation the owner
of the mill itself would retain
ownership it'd be the utility uh that
would be something that would be sold if
the mill changed ownership but it
wouldn't just become
suddenly the property of of Brookfield
uh for lack of a better other way to
phrase it
does that answer your question okay and
and the the way the the bill was written
allows for that without the need for
other it it accepts changes in LA in in
ownership and whatnot without the need
to have to come back here to see you
folks
thank you Mr chairman
thank you
any other comments about
all right seeing none let's move on to
Senate bill
relative to the regulation and operation
charging stations I should say comments
on Senate bill 42.
52.
representative partial
knowing that uh
there is at least a couple of other
amendments out there dealing with EV
charging one being one that I believe
that our Sheriff here introduced
do you think it may be possible to look
at some amendments to this particular
bill
I would guess that would depend on how
extensive the amendments were because
we'd have to have them in Hand by
tomorrow
so that would mean filing them with OLS
okay another possibility would be to
retain this bill and deal with it later
then we'd have plenty of time to amend
it
um may I you may um thank you if it were
retained we would not be looking at it
until
I I really don't know what I think I'll
be honest with you I I I even think I'm
neutral on it right now
representative McGee
thank you Mr chair I think
did we did we pose a question to someone
on was it this bill or a different bill
that we were asking whether they thought
the bills
that the commission should be merged or
the committee should be merged was that
this bill
Bill yes it was this bill sets up a
committee
as I recall
that right here yeah and I think I think
the answer was no that they were doing
two different things
yes that was the answer we heard so that
I just thought of that when I heard
representative partial's question that
maybe that might help clarify whether or
not we should be considering rolling um
you know the mission of a different
piece of legislation and would this one
might make it
okay good point
uh representative mums I think I think
that we also during the testimony we
heard that section four of the Bills
should be deleted
that's a relatively simple amendment
that I'd be happy to submit if
people agree
okay
representative munz will put you on the
case for that
submitting a separate Amendment for that
Mr chair
so I guess what I would ask then is if
there's any other changes we want to
make to the bill we try to roll those
um
well I can tell you in in general terms
that
um
there doesn't seem to be other than the
a lot of
usefulness in this legislation
and
knowing that creating more study
committees is something that leadership
doesn't doesn't favor at this point in
time
I'm wondering if if either ital or
retain would be the solution to this to
this bill I don't see it going forward
representative Thomas
I think Mr
along those lines
um I I do have some some issues with
some of the
potential sources of funding that they
have for these the committee that would
be studying all of them would involve
either some type of a surcharge or or
subsidy uh more like a hidden tax
um you know I think we should you know
if if this bill passed at all we'd have
to we would have to eliminate all those
potential sources as a as as potential
sources because that's just increasing
you know
the bills
so do I understand you correctly that
you're talking about the
the duties that the study committee
would have to look at right identify
additional and uh sources of
non-rapear sources of funding right yeah
just it opens the door too much for
increasing your bill right
further comments representative closure
thank you Mr chair yes representative uh
Thomas Doug
brought up the same thing I was
to me when I read that all they're doing
is
saying that the rate pairs won't pay but
the taxpayers will and they gave seven
examples that's my issue it just
someone else is paying not the right
paid
okay good point
additional comments representative
Carmen has one
thank you Mr chairman
um I I don't read all of these possible
funding mechanisms as pushing onto
taxpayers for example EV registration
surcharges that's for people with EVS
surcharges on electricity purchased
through public electric vehicle charging
stations that's that's a user fee
and the the bill says potential sources
of funding may include but are and are
not limited to these items so it's just
listing some possibilities uh it would
really be up to this the committee to
decide what sources to to use
to to all that I want to add the
importance of the testimony about the
tourism industry
um I mean this is something I was
thinking about and talking about when I
was campaigning last summer just
thinking about how we do get most of our
tourists driving from Southern New
England New York New Jersey they're
going to our ski areas they're hiking
and if and we're going to see more and
more EVS regardless of what we would
like to see they're coming you know what
we think doesn't matter what Mary Barra
chair chair of the board of GM thinks
that's what matters
and
if
if tourists feel like well I can get to
New Hampshire I just don't know that I
can get home they're not going to come
here and we're going to feel that
throughout the state so I believe that
we really do need to be looking at this
and get ahead of it
foreign
representative Arrington
I would say that's all fine and good but
uh if the tourists want to come let them
pay so if there's going to be a
surcharge on those that's fine but I
don't want to see uh State utility
property tax credits local tax
exemptions room and meals tax or any
other type of tax going to fund these
let the people who use the service pay
okay additional comments representative
McGee
yes thank you Mr chair
um Bliss kind of makes my point for me
but that's I think the point of the the
committee is that they need to look at
the potential funding sources and try
and determine which way New Hampshire is
going to go so I think they're going to
be examining uh how each of these works
so that they can come up with a policy
that actually meets our needs it doesn't
mean that any of these are particularly
going to be selected it just means they
should be in the pot for consideration
because they represent funding sources
that are available that's all
so I I think it just makes the case that
it's a bill that probably should pass so
okay let's now talk about Senate bill
54. now this is a big and uh complicated
Bill we heard lots of Pros lots of cons
and uh now we got to decide what we're
I'm anxious to hear what you might think
is this something we should move forward
with is this something that's going to
require more study
what's uh what's the deal here
representative Wendy Thomas
I would like the committee to consider
retaining this bill so that we could
work on some of the language
specifically the maze to shells and the
addition of of prioritizing New
Hampshire projects over other state
okay
additional comments about
representative Harrington yeah thank you
um
there's an awful lot in this bill and
it's very very complicated and
um
as I said I looked into it and checked
with some people and purchased power
Agreements are more being in the 10 to
15 year range than 20 but on the
balancing side if you're going to be if
it's going to be qualified for
transmission then you probably have to
go with the 20 years I'm still not sure
of reading this where it talks about
what's what's considered acceptable
where it talks about that uh electric
energy sources so I guess that could be
read to say that new transmission say
from Hydro Quebec which I think would
probably be a
first big one we could get actually uh
but that could be lawyer to death too in
the courts and I think that that part
needs to be cleared uh clarified so it's
clearly that it can be either generate
new generation or new transmission
um and there's a few other things in
here that I just I I would think this
needs to have a little bit more
inspection before we do something this
big I know there's somewhat of a time
limit we are acting somewhat as a result
of the prices we saw this winter but
remember the actual wholesale prices
with 30 percent lower
it was just the retail prices that were
higher this winter so I would say this
is probably ripe for being retained and
we could look at it literally closely
because this is a major change
one of the other things we heard a lot
about is does it how does it affect the
other part of the Electoral contracts
the six six year of the six month ones
that go out and puc is looking at this
and I just think we ought to pull that
together and maybe we want to have some
options so you know the puc has the
authority to say well based on what
we're looking at now they can go up for
a year-long contract or a three-month
contract whatever it is but there's just
a lot of stuff that needs to be pulled
together and this is a major major
policy change because it's a shift away
from the restructuring markets that we
set up I just think it needs a little
bit more time to look at and possibly
representative Doug Thomas has a comment
thank you Mr chair I agree with the two
previous representative statements This
is highly complicated and probably most
best worked out uh by being retained I
do have some problems with um uh the uh
20-year statement perhaps it could be
rewarded to reflect the in certain areas
transmission versus other types that
should be that could be worked out when
we retain this bill and I'm not sure I
totally agree about changing the the May
statements to Shell so I think there's
some things to be to be discussed here
and retaining is probably the best
action
foreign
okay another option to retain if we
think this bill needs further study
would be to
open the pub the exact session tomorrow
and then
uh
end it or or resume it
no what's the word of the recess it
resets it until a future date and we
have a couple of weeks we could we could
spend looking at it so that's an
alternative to think about
we don't have to say tomorrow yes no or
retain we could we could put it off for
a week or two
one of the reasons I set up the exact
session for tomorrow
was to find out just where we were on
these bills to figure out if there
wasn't a need
for
adding extra time onto any of these
bills so that's another thing to think
about
thank you Mr chairman overall I've
probably made this pretty clear in my
questions overall 54 FN SP 54 FN I'm I'm
completely against it and I'm just
straight out because of a the uh the
contract requirements any length of time
discrepancy if they can't the company
distributor the generator can't meet
those demands and then also skin in the
game too it even mentions here on one of
the pages where the difference would be
taken care of by the the distribution
rate payers and the where the utilities
have no skin in the game at all it all
falls on the ratepayers so I'm
completely against it
okay
any additional comment on Senate Bill
54. representative McGee yeah the the
thought I would add is that I I look at
the bill and I see uh a lot of attempts
to try and bring it to where it needs to
be and so it started out as one thing
and then it kind of morphed into
something else with an amendment that
took certain sections of it in a
different direction and I do think it
needs some attention and also some
more discussion around what we're
ultimately trying to achieve
um I think a lot of the testimony was
clear but it seems like it's a bill that
depending on who's testifying on it it's
in the eye of the beholder and I would
like to have a greater sense of you know
what we are achieving with the bill are
we helping to lower rates are we helping
reliability are we helping to diversify
you know our energy are we trying to
make sure there's more in-state energy
all those things were were items that
were mentioned in the testimony but I
think if we were a little more clearly
focused about what the Bill's objectives
are and whether we're not whether we're
going to be achieving them by what we're
putting in that we'd be happier with it
so I'm for retaining it I'm not sure we
can get it where it needs to go
um in a couple of days but
um you know I'll I'll defer to the
subcommittee to spend a week looking at
this bill
would that get us anywhere does anybody
think we could get anywhere with with
that kind of a an approach
representative Harrington I think we
need more time because I would like to
get the puc's input on this because
they've been looking into this and they
may be able to shed a lot of light on
where you want to go and where you don't
want to go and trying to set that up and
Rush something out just to say we're
doing something I would rather get it
right and if that means waiting till
September I I think that would be a
Preferred Choice
foreign
representative Summers
Mr chairman the key points to me that
I'd be willing to go along with a
retainer work on this bill so long as
page three line 18 and 19 was stricken
okay
all right let's move on uh I guess
tomorrow will be the
the decider for this bill
will have to vote
to do something with it tomorrow
all right Senate Bill 68 which is
relative to the municipal host for
purposes of
LIPA
we actually already passed the house
already passed how House Bill 139 which
is kind of this bill with a little bit
more so I I suspect that
we might as well just pass this bill
just to uh
go along with the Senate I don't see any
reason not to anybody have any
Senate bill sorry representative Corman
yeah thank you Mr Truman
um there the bill uh the Senate bill is
not exactly the same as the one that
passed the house though
right there there is a slight difference
right there is a difference yes yeah
yeah the Senate bill is actually the
amendment that
um did not pass in this committee
correct so uh so if if we pass it then
it will still have to go to conference
is that right
no not necessarily what would happen the
Senate would probably just concur with
the alternative would would be we could
kill this bill since they have 139 in
hand
any appetite for that
no I don't want to kill it
representative McGee yeah this is just
um
I was gonna say locker room talk that's
not what it is but this scuttlebutt on
the street is that uh that really the
the support for getting it over the
governor's desk was the Senate Bill 68
was going to be the vehicle at least
that's what I heard is that the
preference of the Senate not that it has
to be our preference and actually to
representative corman's Point uh I
believe it was uh Dr Krishan who had put
in
the the language that we didn't pass
which became Senate Bill 68 so I don't
think we have any reason not to vote for
it that's my opinion we'll do that then
mm-hmm Center Bill 69
which creates a new customer generator
anybody have any reaction to that bill
my reaction would be that we don't need
to create
new groups for
customer generators new definitions for
customer generators the department of
energy already warned us that doing so
would be a dangerous precedent so I
would not be in favor of moving forward
with this bill but I'd be interested to
representative McGee thank you Mr
chairman
um I think this gets back to that we're
seeing a lot of requests for carve outs
because we don't have you know the one
to five megawatt policy in place for
folks that want to invest here but I I
look at this bill as as really
um
various aspects of our constituency just
asking us to give them a break on their
bills just like many of the other
efforts that we're pursuing so
I see it as some of the large off-takers
of Power are saying you know let us make
this economically available to us to to
make these Investments and we're willing
to make these Investments so that we can
lower our costs so I I have a positive
disposition towards SB 69
doesn't making something economically
viable for one group
disadvantage some other group that would
be my well that's the problem with this
kind of legislation that's uh that's one
philosophy it's kind of a zero-sum game
thing but I think if we're trying to get
people to we're saying why aren't people
investing I think this is why people
aren't investing because so far we've
put our thumb on the scale the other way
to say yeah we're not going to give you
any incentive to do that investing for
us so that we have a more diverse Energy
Mix
so
representative muns thank you
um the nonprofit sector is one of the
largest employers in the state and their
operating margins are incredibly small
and anything we can do to enable them to
continue to be able to function and
provide the service the very important
services that people rely on in the
state and keep those people employed is
something that I think we should be
encouraging and so I I Echo what
representative McGee is saying I think
it's important to move forward
representative Harrington
yeah this is another uh step that we've
been doing way way too much over the
last 20 years and that's we think
something's a good idea and we want to
pay for it we don't want to put a tax
out there and use the word tax so we
hide it in electric rates so I'm opposed
to this like I'd be opposed to anything
you think this is a great idea sponsor a
bill and says
we'll put a tax on everyone's electric
rates when they get their bill it says
oh I'm paying a dollar and a half tax
this month for subsidizing some program
that someone thinks is a good idea be
open transparent about it don't hide it
in the electric bills
further comment representative Corman
thank you Mr chairman I have to confess
I have a certain affinity for
non-profits I'm on the development
committee of a non-profit and I'm also
the grant writer and I just know how
hard it is to for non-profits to fund
what they do and I feel like anything we
can do I mean you know us the science
technology and energy committee what can
we do for non-profits this is something
that we can do for non-profits to make
their lives a little easier and allow
them to do a little bit more
representative Reynolds thank you Mr
chairman um yeah again uh this bill is
about simply removing an arbitrary
restriction that has been placed on the
scale of
renewable development that makes it
extremely difficult economically to make
them make sense we've heard numerous
folks testify over the past few months
about how restricting development of
Renewables solar in particular to one
megawatt forces the all of the
interconnection costs to be borne by a
very relatively small project and this
Committee in this legislature and its
wisdom
remove that restriction for
municipalities because everyone lives in
a municipality well as representative
Mudd said you know New Hampshire so much
of our economy is various non-profits
large and small from YMCAs to
you know you name it and uh
this would again it's just nothing free
about this Market we set the rules and
this this one megawatt limitation on the
scale of
renewable generation that's allowed to
interconnect is is what's holding us
back
um these projects are done through
private investment not public
and so I think that this bill has a lot
further comment
I'd point out that
the municipal host carve out that we
benefits taxpayers and it's also uh some
under under the control of taxpayers
because they control their Municipal
spending
and so if they choose
the benefits that they reap from being
part of a municipal host program
they can choose to use that money
however they like
and so they have some control over it
turning groups into of non-profits into
the benefits
except
how the non-profit wants to use it so it
provides less
public benefit than being a municipal
host provides and it seems to me that
it's ripe for abuse and that would be
another reason why I couldn't really
support something like this without some
anybody else have anything else to say
representative Wendy Thomas you might
want to turn your microphone off oh
okay
let's move on Senate Bill 79 this is the
same kind of Bill as Senate Bill 69
except it talks about industrial hosts
rather than
non-profit hosts and I think It suffers
from many of the same problems that
the previous bill that we just discussed
suffers from and for that reason I
couldn't support it even though it's
supported by the business and industry
Association
I'm a little bit baffled by that one but
um
well it appears Wendy representative
Wendy Thomas says thank you um so
your your objection to these this bill
and the previous one is there's no guard
rails I mean should we be considering
guard rails for these to make them
stronger bills
we could certainly consider it
um
it might require retaining those bills
in order to do so but I'm a little bit
reluctant to retain bills because we
already have 13 of them well but I mean
if we if if it if it means we we put out
a good bill or a strong bill
so your objection to both of these are
our guard rails essentially
yeah there's no
uh
Assurance built into the bill that the
program how fast the programmer will
grow how big the program will grow
it's it's open-ended and
representative McGee
thank you Mr chairman so
um on the on SB 79 which is the bill at
hand
um I felt felt that the testimony from
both hitchner and Stonyfield was
extremely compelling and what we were
hearing from them is just as with sb69
these are folks that have exorbitant
energy bills right so there's the so
when prices go up 50 or 100 percent the
impact is very significant both on
non-profits and on uh for-profit large
operations so I I heard their testimony
as asking us to pay attention to that
and to try and figure out a way to allow
them to help themselves right they can
make an investment but they also have
all of the capital costs and even though
they will reap the benefits it's it's
it's hard for them to make the
Investments at the right at the
appropriate scale because they're not
going to be compensated for the energy
that they produce at a rate to measure
it with what its actual value would be
in the market so that's all they're
asking us to do is to allow them to
participate in you know creating some
local generation which which I think is
a benefit to this system
so I don't I don't really view it the
same way as some others that have spoken
here and I think that as was mentioned
before
if it's a hospital or YMCA or other
large organization with big facilities
and they get to save on their bill and
they get to generate their own energy
they're also helping us lower demand you
know so the conversations we had earlier
in the day about how we're worried about
Peak and where we're going to get it
from if the more we allow people to
invest in New Hampshire the more energy
independent we become so
I think we have to start looking at that
because the testimony that we had that
day on SP 79
was clear cogent compelling I mean I
couldn't see any reason to to deny them
what they were asking for from us I
thought it was eminently reasonable in
the environment that we're in which is
that prices have gone up significantly
and they're impacting everybody every
sector so since we don't have an overall
energy policy that allows them to
participate and have it become an
economically reasonable investment for
them they're saying carve it out for us
and I agree with you I don't want I
don't want to see it be all one-offs I
don't think that's the way to do it but
that's where we are because we don't we
don't allow people to invest over one
megawatt
and get reimbursed what's interesting
about your argument is that
we don't prevent people from making
Investments over one megawatt if they
want to make investments over one
megawatt they can
they can make it today right they don't
need any additional help from from us
well I think to make that the argument
has been that it's non-economical for
them to make the investment because
that's where the price point is that
they end up you know seeing the the
benefits of the investment which is what
any investment investor is looking for
right is where's the break point when am
I going to recover my money what's the
return on investment so it it becomes
non-economical and therefore people it's
depressed the Market's depressed right
people are not going to make the
investment because it just doesn't make
economic sense
representative Harrington
yeah this is just another car vote we
started with this was being one megawatt
only then we went up to five and we said
it was okay for municipals then we just
talked about uh non-profits and now
we're talking about corporations and as
you said there's nothing that prevents
they can make a 10 megawatt system if
they want to there's nothing preventing
them from doing that they could invest
in storage and use 100 of their
electricity but instead they wanted to
take the easy route out and sell it back
to uh the utility at an inflated price
because it's not what it's worth because
they don't have any obligation to serve
so they can put out three and a half
four megawatts on a Sunday morning a
bright Sunday morning in May when no one
really needs the power and the prices
the wholesale price is very low but
they're still going to get paid the
higher rate and in another time on a
cold Winter's day they can produce
nothing and there's no penalty so to say
this is the same is PR as regular power
is is just isn't true there's no one's
this stuff is worth substantially less
than say the default Service uh you get
from a utility because you turn on the
lights and they're supposed to come on
and the utility has a contract with
someone to provide electricity 24 7.
these people don't have contracts with
anybody they can produce as much of as
little power as they want the only
obligation is whenever they decide to do
it someone has to buy it and pay an
inflated price so carve out after Cabo
pretty soon we're going to have
everybody can do five megawatts and then
it's really going to start shifting
costs and it won't be any need to use
the electricity just be like many little
generators and that'll really Drive our
costs up
additional comments representative
closure
thank you Mr chair I just looking over
um
Mr Roberts from the Department of energy
brought on the fact that we're repealing
the the present eligible consumer
generator and just redefining it and
expanding it to far more than what it
was that's the main thing it is what
this bill does it redefines
uh eligible customer
generator thank you
good point
representative Summers
thank you Mr chairman actually I'm just
actually picking up on some of the
things that have been said here and I've
just made me wonder that uh we've all
looking at 69 and 79 non-profit
we already carved out like you like
um representative Harrington said we
already carved out municipalities 69 ads
not would add non-profits to it 79 ads
Industries
who would not who would not be allowed
to have net metering of all these paths
that's my question might be like
everybody would be able to good question
representative Wendy Thomas thank you
um so we as as we learn things we're
redefining uh terms and and conditions
might this not be seen as the evolution
of the energy process in the in in New
Hampshire I mean isn't this what we're
supposed to be doing
right
well learning and growing it would be a
valid criteria and as I indicated in my
initial comments I met a few minutes ago
about 69
it's all about managing growth in my
judgment and this is not a good way to
management growth to throw it open to
anybody and everybody so that's why I
would oppose this kind of approach
representative partial
thank you chair I'd like to I think I
might have indicated this before I
really don't see this as anything more
than a good job bill it's good business
for us to raise the limit to five
megawatts so companies like Ann Houser
Bush can produce more of their own
electric and not have to lay off
employees and send money out of state
let's keep the money in state and let's
keep our employees working
I think it's pretty cut and dried as far
as I can say and I have to agree with a
representative of Summers
I get tired of the car abouts too I
think it'd be far easier for me to raise
the entire uh limit to five megawatts
representative Carmen thank you Mr
chairman
um there it seems to me there is a bit
of a guard rail on this one right
because it says in no instance shall the
electrical generating facility exceed
100 of the industrial host's average
electric consumption over the past 12
months so there there is a bit of a
limit and after after that then then
they're getting a wholesale for it
you're right there is a little bit of a
guardrail on this one and my judgment is
not nearly big enough but
additional comments
representative Wendy Thomas thank you um
I don't have the answer to this so I'm
throwing it out to the committee but um
with the existing carbs out is there any
I mean do we do multiple host you mean
yes well there was uh not Crossing
Municipal boundaries was a
was one of the guardrails but we've done
away with that right right so so this
these wouldn't be as self-regulating
representative Harrington
again I just want to say that it's just
to say that there's a guardrail or a
limit because they could only uh do up
to the maximum amount that they consume
in a year doesn't deal with the reality
of the markets they can be producing in
fact they probably would produce the
maximum amount of their solar output
would be in the month of May probably
the first half of May and two sevenths
of that is going to come on Saturdays
and Sundays during very low demand days
because it's weekends and even on the
weekday in May typically that's
considered that's when we shut down the
nuclear plants for refueling Etc because
demand for electricity is lowest then so
the value is the lowest so they're going
to be producing the maximum amount when
the value is the lowest and again that's
so I'm sensing that we're kind of split
on this these two bills representative
McGee yeah just a last thought I I feel
like we're going back and litigating
some conversations that we've had in the
past and it comes down to
um
you know not letting this Market do
whatever it would do based on a free
market because of a concern for any
shifting of costs right isn't that
where where you come down in terms of
opposing the idea of people making their
own Investments for their own energy
needs and giving them the latitude to do
that and be paid for the energy that
they're generating at a reasonable rate
um you know to to recover those those
Capital costs
um it's it's more out of a concern that
somebody else is going to have to pay
for that or subsidize that
um and I I don't I think that the vder
study that we just got shows us that
even out to 2035 we're really not
looking at any significant cost shifts
and so I'm wondering if we should still
be laboring under that perception that
that is something that we're supposed to
be managing for when people are
desperately asking us to help them
manage their energy costs right now
well I think representative McGee that
you hit on the the
crucial part of this question and that
is what's the what's a reasonable cost
and the current uh docket that's open in
front of the puc is looking into that
very question trying to decide what
should be a reasonable cost for the net
metering tariff going forward that's
another reason I think that bills like
six SB 69 and SB 79 should be set aside
until we know what the cost is going to
be based on whatever net metering tariff
gets developed out of that docket
we either could be setting ourselves up
for huge cost increases or we could be
creating opportunities that are
non-existent which are going to give
people false hope so I think it would be
prudent just to push these
pieces of legislation aside until we
know what a future net meter in tariff
is going to look like
and just so you know I I had that
conversation I think when
um when Mr Roberge was in the hot seat
with him that I I actually see
um correct rate setting of The Tariff
for net metering as uh
separate red herring type of an issue
because if it's set correctly sometime
in the future it it doesn't make any
difference it just means that the rate
that a person will be paid will change
commiserate with that new information
but it doesn't have anything to do with
us passing uh net metering policy today
and I don't think it should
uh be delayed because of something
that's that's separate and distinct
which is what the value of the energy is
not whether you have the ability to
recover that value
well I hear from my constituents that a
lot of them are uncomfortable buying
things that they don't know what they
cost so they want to wait to see what it
costs before they say yes to buying
something
any further combats representative Doug
Thomas thank you Mr chair I would have
to agree uh with the comments um to wait
and see what happens with the puc but
the one thing I'd like to State here is
I I would like for everyone here to be
very cautious in using the term that we
need to allow people to you know be able
to go up to five megawatts like the
chair set here nothing prevents them
from from doing that I think the thought
we want to get through is if we want to
say that we want to say that you know we
want we want people to be able to go up
to five megawatts by getting subsidies
and so I think that's the point that I
want to get across here is that we
they're they're allowed to go up up to
five megawatts if they can't afford to
do that that's part of the market but
that's what we're talking about here is
subsidies versus we're not Banning or
allowing or disallowing anyone to go any
any higher up up to five megawatts it's
so it's the whole question is what what
do they get out of it back and that's
the whole issue right here so I just
representative Reynolds
thank you Mr chairman and I I can't let
that point go without pushing back on it
uh
the whole debate here of course comes
down to the net metering rate
and
the value of
distributed energy study long-awaited
multiple years awaited came back and
said there was a less than one percent
cost shift and that less than one
percent was
under the
worst case assumptions
so there's no cost shift by
paying for net metered energy at the
retail rate
back to representative Harrington's
comments first of all the peak
nope not wrong and uh
secondly the reason that it's not a cost
shift the reason that it deserves to be
paid for at the retail rate and not the
wholesale rate is because when net
metered energy goes back onto the grid
it's already on the grid it goes to the
next closest meter where there is demand
so
it doesn't incur distribution costs or
and it certainly doesn't incur long-term
transmission costs so net metered energy
meets a key
demand in the grid
and so it's it's not a huge cost shift
and it's not a subsidy to be paying the
retail rate for net metered energy
representative Harrington
yeah first I'll stand by my statement
because solar panels the height of solar
incidences June 20th in uh New Hampshire
and because of the way the panels work
when they get high temperatures like in
July and August which would be they'll
be less efficient and put out less
electricity than they would in May where
it's cooler and the solar incidence is
exactly the same but the main issue here
is if you start we've got it now for we
want it for public housing we want it
for uh municipalities we wanted for
counties now we want it for industrial
places you're going to start getting
hundreds and hundreds of megawatts on
the grid with no obligation to deliver
and so if the thunderstorm comes in a
little bit early or a cold wave comes in
and most of the solar drops off by 50
percent More Than People expected
but we have to get back up power to make
up for that there's utilities the iso
New England is going to have a
increasedly reserved margin
substantially because they realize you
put four or 500 megawatts on the grid
that has no obligation to deliver like a
regular generator that creates a lot
more uncertainty and everybody wants
electricity oops the cold front came in
early is not an adequate excuse why your
lights don't work so they're going to
turn around and say we want more
spinning Reserve well they have to pay
for the spinning Reserve so the costs go
up there's just no other way to look at
it when it's a small amount it's
negligible the one percent was
remembering that report was up to one
megawatt of net metering not going to
five and certainly not expanding it to
any industrial facility in the state
that had a load of that could go up to
five megawatts so there's a drastically
load shifted because as we heard earlier
about risk this increases the risk to
the supplying utility or the iso New
England whoever you want to talk about
balancing it because it's simply more
more risk involved because these
companies do not have an obligation
their inverters break on Tuesday maybe
they'll fix them Wednesday or Thursday
maybe they won't maybe they'll wait
three weeks they have no obligation
there's no penalty for not delivering
the electricity but whenever they do
I think we can all get a pretty good
idea based on the discussion we've just
heard over the last 15 20 minutes that
we're probably not going to come to any
kind of an agreement over these two
bills
nor have we identified any way to
improve them I don't think that's
basically the purpose of a work session
is to look at bills and see if we can
wait think of ways to
improve them make them better make them
work better and I think it likely makes
based on the discussion we just had
we're not going to make either of these
bills any better one way or the other
so let's move on to Senate Bill 113
relative to cost effectiveness
a car relative to cost Effectiveness
review of The Joint utility Energy
Efficiency plan it's not worded very
well but anyway what that means
basically is that um
Senate Bill 113 wanted to add the word
annually to the section of law that
describes the system benefits charge
because the puc interpreted the previous
legislation that we passed in House Bill
549 as meeting a lifetime and annual
Energy savings
and this bill clarifies that by saying
that it's just annual Energy savings not
lifetime
and
I think uh it would be reasonable since
that was one of the guard rails that was
put into HB 549 if we're going to weaken
that guardrail we should strengthen the
other guardrail so I will be submitting
an amendment that removes the
0.25 percent adder
to the system benefits charge
uh
CPI
adjustment that's made every three years
so we'll this amendment will delete that
0.25 Adder which will strengthen that
guard rail since we're weakening the
other guard rail and I think uh that's
the kind of an improvement to this bill
that would make it acceptable to both
sides and we could probably pass that
unanimously
I haven't gotten the bill back from OLS
it's been filed I haven't checked my
email recently but last time I looked it
and I don't see it yet so I asked for it
by three o'clock this afternoon it is
three o'clock but
not there yet but anyway that's what my
Amendment will do and uh
foreign any comments representative
McGee
thank you Mr chair as we discussed this
um I I don't I don't agree that
um clarifying that we should have annual
in there to explicitly let the puc
understand that we don't mean lifetime
which no one had ever interpreted it
that way before is weakening something
so that we have to then make something
else stronger but I I think removing the
um the adder is not significant enough
to hold up the bill I think the bill is
is a no-brainer to quote my colleague on
representative munz thank you so that
that change you're proposing in your
Amendment it doesn't change the language
in this bill per se it affects some
other clause
yes it is it affects
um
Clause two I believe
is that correct I don't have it right in
front of me
oh so you're changing another section
another paragraph the paragraph right
any other comments
okay moving on to House Bill a Senate
Bill 161 which is relative to low
moderate income Community solar projects
I had sent you all a an amendment last
Friday that was suggested by the
department of energy
and I don't think there's any objection
to that it's amendment number
1346 h
I'm sorry this is on 161.
okay we're good to go with that then
next step is excuse me what was the
amendment I'm trying to get this it's
amendment
1346h I sent it to your legislative
I don't I don't have that
it's not in the computer yet did it I
don't see it listed
we have copies here at all actually I
have copies in my desk drawer I can go
get them
I I have the language here right talks
them on to yourselves while I go to my
desk
oh so it adds the rule of order that's
that's what the change is okay thank you
foreign
okay we're passing out the paper copy of
Mr chairman while we're doing on that I
had a comment that doesn't pertain to
the amendment okay uh I'm looking at
this in one of the uh caveats in here is
that people that can get subsidized for
low-income solar make 80 percent of the
area area median income and doing a
quick look if you take the uh area
median income for New Hampshire and
adjust it for inflation that was from
2021 that's eighty thousand dollars and
so someone could make seventy five
thousand dollars I don't think they're
in need of a subsidy if they're living
in public housing they're already
getting a subsidy and there's a lot of
people in New Hampshire that make less
than 80 000 that are living in an
apartment or living in a trailer or
living in a small house and they'll be
paying higher electric rates to
subsidize these people who again already
getting subsidized housing now they're
going to get subsidized electricity I
just think it's way too much money
and again it's the same old thing hide
the hide the thing in the electric bill
if you want to subsidize people to put
solar in put attacks out there let
people know what they're paying
okay Mr chairman on that point yes if
they say area median income then is
Manchester gonna have the same as you
know Lebanon or Hanover I I think area
media income becomes more specific right
I believe it is broken out by different
areas and it says calculated by the
Department of Housing and Urban
Development so I think
um I think it might be a little more
discreet than the way your your concerns
um representative Harrington
representative muns I think I can
actually answer that because I actually
uh downloaded the uh area Inc incomes
and it's it's a whole group of different
uh areas there's there's probably
I'm going to say 20 different
areas in New Hampshire and it's mostly
by county
mostly by County yeah and they and they
carve out Nashua and Manchester as
separate uh entities
okay traditional comment representative
munz so I'm I just can you explain what
your amendment is and what it does
yes so in the in the lines of
six and lines 15 it allows the
department of energy to develop rules
or issue orders to develop the process
and the means by which these low
moderate income Community solar projects
are created and operated
and then there is additional language
down in
um starting on lines 25 and running
through lines 30.
that specify
that well this was a that was already in
there this was already in the bill
except for the word
uh on line 26 as described in the
original bill that was as defined
and excuse me
the
RSA to which as defined referred doesn't
actually Define anything all it does is
it points to Federal legislation
so changing the word as defined to as
described was determined to be
a more accurate way to
um
make that reference and the same change
was made on line 16 in on page two so
those are the those are the changes
they're relatively small relatively
minor thank you
further descriptive
discussion
representative Summers
thank you Mr chairman
um I know I mentioned it over here when
we were discussing the only thing I have
an issue with is the uh in some
municipalities eighty percent of the
area of median income might be a little
okay
any other comments
representative Mickey yeah my comment is
on the changes that say by rule or order
of the Department of energy
um I wasn't under the impression I
didn't know that
the department of energy made rules or
orders like I traditionally would see
rules and orders coming out of the
Public Utilities Commission so I'm just
curious
why that language is is there and if
that is customary I know you and I when
we had a conversation I mentioned
regulatory versus you know an agency and
so if you could just clarify that
because it looks like it's new language
sure so all uh executive departments
have regulatory Authority Department of
Transportation Department of Health and
Human Services on and on and they all
make rules that's what RSA 541a is all
about it's rulemaking Authority for
executive departments
so the if if you'll recall when we
passed hb2 back in 2021
the the bill that broke up the Public
Utilities Commission into the the new
puc and the department of energy
part of the legislation in hb2
directed
and subsequent legislation that we
passed in in this committee and in the
house in the Senate directed the
department to develop rules
regulatory rules and so what this means
in this legislation is that
Community solar projects are a area
where
Department of energy rules May apply
so
um
sorry I had to answer my phone so
basically what this
clarification to the legislation does is
it shows that the department
may use its rulemaking Authority or its
authority to
create orders
to con to
um
control the way that these low-income
Community solar projects are created and
operated
does that make does that explain it yeah
I think it's a good explanation I I
think it it represents a change I think
the other agencies that we're discussing
like Transportation they don't have a
Utilities Commission you know they don't
have
um a body that generally produces the
orders around various energy projects so
that's why I was just it seemed like a
change to me to say that they were going
to start producing the orders that would
allow
without putting you on the spot Mr
Roberts could I ask you to come up and
say a few words about the departments
thank you members of the committee again
Griffin Roberts Department of energy so
the it is correct the department did
request the language in Amendment 1346 H
regarding the changes on line six and
line 15 which is the Bold uh Language by
rule or order this stems or I should say
this amendment amends a state statute
that's created in Senate Bill 270 from
last year as you might recall that bill
required the department to establish a
program to identify low to moderate
income customers who could participate
in these LMI Community solar projects
um
as you'll see in the bill um the
department
um have is required to uh
uh create administrative rules
um for the program the department uh
brought forward this amendment because
it would take substantial time for the
Department to create those rules at the
same time that we are uh revising our
rules given the breakup between the puc
and the doe
um and given that is our understanding
that the legislative intent was that
this program would be up much sooner
um we submitted this a language that
will allow the department to issue
orders to develop uh requirements around
this LMI program we certainly could
proceed without administrative rule
however that would leave the department
vulnerable uh to potentially Bad actors
who could file poor or mediocre
applications that the doe would be
unable to deny because the only backup
we have is what's currently existing in
statute we do not have the
administrative rules that would back
that up so to ensure that we have the
the those um
guardrails and it has been tossed around
quite a bit today those guard rails in
place and to make sure that the
legislative intent is met that we move
this program along having the
flexibility and statute to issue orders
um would help us kind of bridge that Gap
until administrative rules are formally
thank you for that clarification I think
that helps us understand exactly what
what the intent of this uh Amendment
would be representative McGee
sorry
so
am I understanding you correct that
you're saying that the rules may not be
ready for a while but you want to be
able to put orders out before the rules
are complete yes uh that's that's
correct so we'd like to issue guard
rails around the program by order until
administrative rules are formally
adopted through the formal rulemaking
process
if that makes sense yeah well I I guess
my question would be how do you define
what guard rails are appropriate if you
don't have established rules that you've
discussed sure trying to figure out what
should be going around and I appreciate
that I believe there is a stakeholder
process by which a lot of this takes
place and they're already there already
has been regarding this LMI Community
solar program that was developed through
Senate bill 270.
um it's my understanding the department
issued a letter to interested
stakeholders here relatively a short
time ago indicating that they're we're
aiming to release an RFP sometime soon
regarding that program so again
stakeholders are involved throughout the
process I think the goal is to you know
not overstep and certainly not supersede
The rulemaking Authority by just issuing
an order and we're all done I think the
order would really be viewed as maybe a
stop Gap until those rules are formally
done and adjudicated and formally put in
place if that makes sense and to your
other point the department does
um have the authority under statute to
issue orders for example just a recent
one
um what was it under State Statute the
department has the authority to
administratively lower
um class three obligations under the RPS
for example we just kind of issued an
order recently after a stakeholder
process to lower that obligation
thank you appreciate you taking a
question on short notice
further comments on Senate Bill 161
seeing none let's move on Senate Bill
166 relative to grid modernization and I
believe representative McGee has an
amendment to 150 166.
and it actually uses language that
um
I suggested as well as some language
that she suggested so
uh representative Mickey why don't you
tell us about it thank you
um yes so it's Amendment uh 2023 1392h
and it's hot off the presses
um the chairman and I talked last well
over the weekend uh went over a bunch of
bills and he had told me that there were
a couple of changes which you see
between lines 5 and 12.
um that he had intended to
bring in in an amendment on this bill
there was also pending language on
helping to clarify and really instruct
what um what the legislature would like
to see done in terms of
when reviewing these types of projects
because there seems to be some lack of
clarity around how that's to be done and
so the language that's online 27 through
32 at the bottom of the page
it's taken from some language that was I
guess started in I think it was 321
which must be 321 which passed last year
um it started there but then it got a
little uh convoluted in the version that
I was reading so I tried to rewrite it
to make it clearer and so basically it
says such credit shall be based upon the
extent to which such exports to the
distribution grid reduce retail loads
calculated at the point of
interconnection between the distribution
system under State jurisdiction and
Transmissions facilities under Federal
jurisdiction and the extent to which the
actual transmission costs allocated to
the distribution utility Network
customer are reduced from what they
would be absent the electricity exported
to the distribution grid by the Limited
producer so it's basically clarifying
what should be taken into account
and how it should be looked at
so that language helps to make this
portion under Pilots clearer in terms of
um how they'll be set up because it's
it's kind of new territory so that's the
reason for that language
and so those are all the changes that we
were aware of now in one in one
Amendment
and I've discussed these changes with
the
a few a few different people and I
concur that these changes are worth
making and will make Senate Bill 166 a
stronger bill
see now let's move on to Senate Bill 167
and I believe we have a proposed
amendment for that one too
that's amendment number 1391 H submitted
by
Representatives Kaplan and McGee and
representative Kaplan you want to tell
us about this amendment
yeah thank you Mr chair um
as I think I mentioned before and during
the public hearing this amendment uh
basically goes through and makes all the
language consistent so that we know
we're talking about Green hydrogen and a
build to incentivize green hydrogen
it also
um adds language that was suggested by
the Department of Revenue Administration
to make the taxing the credit much
clearer at the end paragraph one section
seven is replaced with uh that final
that's all this stuff this is a very
very simple Amendment
uh basically it makes sure that the
definition of green hydrogen is
consistent throughout by
removing any lines that might be
ambiguous
any questions about the amendment or
reactions to it representative Wendy
Thomas thank you Mr chair
um the the last line let me see where is
it 11 and 12 the term does not include
hydrogen produced using steam I thought
that
when when they presented the bill they
were talking about using the steam from
Seabrook and that seems like a free
source of of energy so why is that in
there
can you be clear about what where where
you see that about stuff um page one uh
lines 11 and 12. all right well it
starts on 11 it goes to to 12 and 13.
the term does not include hydrogen
produced using steam
yeah steam reforming I believe that is
I'm not certain but I think that's a
reference to natural gas production
so that so it doesn't exclude the steam
from Seabrook
all right uh representative lewicki has
a question okay this is actually a
clarification what happens excuse me the
steam itself is um not exactly reformed
basically what you do is you combine the
steam with a high temperature
hydrocarbon which can be anything from
charcoal to natural gas to oil or
whatever and that then is actually very
similar to what was done with this gas
holder down the road here that they want
to preserve and so you end up with uh
hydrogen and carbon monoxide and then
can separate out the hydrogen and so
it's a fairly con very old process but
it does you involve either some kind of
hydrocarbon fuel
so this uh to make sure I understand it
exactly what you're getting at here this
last sentence says that
any hydrogen produced using steam
reforming or any other conversion
technology
that produces hydrogen from fossil fuel
feedstock
does not meet the definition of green
hydrogen
okay so this doesn't change the original
Bill well okay
yeah as I said
there in the original Bill there were
references to hydrogen that didn't uh
that were ambiguous because it wasn't
clear that we were trying to talk about
green hydrogen so I just added green to
to everywhere where it said hydrogen
um and there were three or four
also online uh section g on line 20 on
on the uh page two line 20 page two
um
there's been a line that was edited and
dropped from that section
that was about uh the line referred to
fossil fuel feed stocks used in
production for hydrogen so as part of
the duties of the advisory committee to
okay additional comment on whether or
not this legislation or this amendment
makes the bill better makes it worst
whatever representative Summers thank
you Mr chairman I'm just looking
actually looking at hydrogen and
hydrogen is becoming very popular but
what I was going to look is the
Restriction here on green hydrogen where
it says it looks like 95 percent of all
hydrogen in the United States is
produced by either gray or blue hydrogen
with only five percent green is this
would this be limiting to us in any way
sounds like it might
other comments do you have a reaction to
that representative Kaplan yeah
absolutely I mean this would limit the
incentives to the tax credits that we
would be offering under this bill to
okay
representative Harrington had some
comments about the the tax incentives
that were part of this bill
yeah basically
um it's it's another uh subsidy and uh
if green hydrogen is a good idea and
it's economical and all this other stuff
why do we have to
um spend five million dollars a year in
tax subsidies on it and is also I don't
have any exact number but the number of
the federal government is tossing around
hydrogen is in the billions and I think
they're going to put and I don't maybe
you could see the I think five or six
hydrogen hubs and if we become one uh
basically most of it's gonna be paid for
by the federal taxpayers if we don't
become one there's no way we can compete
with those that are going to be
subsidized so highly so I'm just not
sure this bill is going to accomplish
anything
representative Reynolds
well I I would just it's timely because
I was going to comment before
representative Harrington's remark but
you know that's the point of this bill
is his green hydrogen is an essent
technology that holds a lot of economic
promise
and so the point of the bill is to not
incentivize what's already happening
where industrial hydrogen is produced
from you know the brown process of
reforming methane but rather uh
like uh catalytic you know the term from
using using renewable energy and
as for New Hampshire becoming
you know if there's a hydrogen Hub
unfortunately New Hampshire is the only
state not there was an article in the
Seacoast paper over the weekend how New
Hampshire is the only state in the
Northeast not participating in the
effort to bring a hydrogen Hub to the
Northeast
um
I think the intent of this bill is is to
have New Hampshire do something as a
state to have a chance of attracting
some uh industry in this important area
if we completely sit it out then we can
pretty much be assured that whatever
investment Private Industry makes in
green hydrogen it won't be in New
Hampshire
representative McGee
thank you Mr chairman
um to follow on that point I actually
was a co-sponsor on this bill and I
talked with Senator Waters a few times
on it and he also as I recall in his
testimony was pretty clear that his
intention was
um to give us enabling legislation that
would allow us to open up to the idea of
you know welcoming some of those federal
dollars and having green hydrogen he was
saying particularly you know where he is
over on the coast that they're looking
at it in terms of transportation and
other uses that are already being
explored in other states and already
being used in other states so I I think
it that's all the intention was and the
reason it was written as a green
hydrogen Bill and all representative
Kaplan and I did was say that we should
make that a consistent reference
throughout the language of the bill the
main change that happens here as a
result of us putting together an
amendment is to make sure that the dra
language which they said could be
tightened up at the end said that it
shall take effect January 1st 2029 and
shall apply to taxable periods beginning
after December 31st 2028 so that was the
correction that
that caused us to do the amendment that
was the substantive change and the rest
of it is really just for consistency's
sake
so we didn't know that there was a
debate on green hydrogen itself as a
technology but um but I just want to
bring you back to Senator Waters
testimony because he did say that there
is a bunch of money that's available and
he was hoping to
make sure that New Hampshire was
eligible for that money and able to
pursue these new technologies if we
okay
is there any place that is actually
using hydrogen in the United States and
any significant quantity or are we
basically talking about something
hypothetical that may or may not have
problems in the future
okay
yeah there are representative months you
might have more detail I I all I would
all I'm doing is looking at the article
that was uh printed in the paper this
weekend and um it makes reference to a
uh
um a project that's going on in
groverton
it'll be the world's first power plant
completely fueled by Clean affordable
clean hydrogen
yeah
representative murder
yes I um the reason they came to New
Hampshire I've been with them for five
years this has kind of been flying I did
meet with Q hydrogen on this bill last
week and to them it's it's indifference
for the five million dollars a year that
the total amount going out was nothing
to be subsidized so uh there'll be a lot
more being offered on Q hydrogen the
next
two months
um so I I was up on the site last
weekend and uh it's coming along pretty
quick so I all I can tell you say is
stay tuned to it
I'm amazed it keeps getting out in the
Press I don't know how it happens but
I've been with them since 2017 on this
so they subscribe to the idea that if
you build a better mousetrap y you'll
okay
you know
anybody else having a comment to make
about 167 and whether or not the
amendment makes it better or worse or
whatever
representative Wendy Thomas yeah no
um if you're asking if the amendment is
better I'm going to agree that yes the
amendment makes it better
okay good
all right no further comment on this one
Let's us move on to the last bill of the
day which is Senate Bill 225
which re-establishes a committee that
existed last year
that was created the year before I
believe
or it might have been created last year
but in any case it it just
re-establishes this commission to
figure out how to assess power plants
for tax purposes and I think
that committee did a good job
last year but it didn't finish its work
and so I think we should reauthorize it
anybody have any
other thoughts representative Corman yes
as I mentioned to you earlier I did put
in for an amendment and I did get it
from OLS so I have an amendment that
corrects an error in and at the
beginning of the bill where it repeals
the wrong RSA and the amendment has the
correct RSA
good we'll adopt that Amendment tomorrow
any further discussion
okay we're done good work session we'll
be back here tomorrow morning at 9 00
A.M
with bells on and we will exec these
bills
and determine their fate
for width thank you for your hard work
today and we'll see you tomorrow
I wasn't interested in seeing that the
he wants to oh it's all going to be in
May and then after that there's you know
no value yeah well it's like well
actually you know if you want to be true
it's pretty steady all summer long May
June July August pretty pretty close
pretty close remember to clean up all
the paperwork around your desks please
higher it's also the length of the day
and so you know it depends